two
hey guys welcome to the hugest event of
the year
the h3 podcast
sound bite championship
thank you guys for joining us this week
um
wait
something seems off guys
yeah are you are you flipped
i am flipped actually hold on
what the flip i'm totally flipped hold
on put me back
up okay that's better i knew something
was weird
i don't like being flat
oh brother
oh man
oh i'm still flipped
is ryan cavanaugh producing the show or
what can we get there can we get things
back on track here please
oh yeah yeah yeah who flip who's flipped
this dang show
holy smokes
yo trailer my thing's flipped
this is not triller proof this is the h3
podcast our stuff is not flipped here
okay
by the way it's a little crooked the uh
you see what i'm saying dan it's a
little [ __ ] crooked there
oh my god ryan cavanaugh has gotten to
the machine or something
today's episode is sponsored by curology
and upstart we love so well thank you
today my friend
you know last year we did the sound bite
tournament and it was one of the most
beloved episodes
of the year
so much fun you know the sound bites are
such a play such a big part
in the show here
and uh
we we love zach for making for you know
making
that it's just such a living personality
i love all you guys really a character
of the show
so today we honor our favorite sound
bites we honor zach and we have a
bracket like a championship brack or the
some lights just went out
we having a championship bracket
for people who didn't see it last year
very fun exciting here let me open the
bracket and what we do is we tell the
story of each sound bite the origin
story
and we battle them a live vote
everybody in the audience votes
on which soundbite is more powerful
as they advance the brackets of
champions
and we will crown a winner of the 2021
h3 podcast
sound bite championship live here today
on this beautiful
winter wednesday
last year the the winner was undisputed
it was shout out to the family
by the way
that one took it like by just
crushed one after the other
now
these are all brand new
or never before battled sound bites we
brought back shout out to the family
because
who knows maybe it's still undefeated
yeah you gotta let the champion have a
chance to defend the crown so shout out
to the families here otherwise they're
all new with the exception by the way we
noticed last year we forgot peace and
love peace and love ringo starr
and so we brought that one in but other
than that they're all brand new and man
the competition is fierce it is stiff we
had a uh a pretty heated debate
yesterday when we were putting this
together
about what will win or what to include
uh what will when
yeah don't don't share your predictions
just yet because i don't want to take
the uh
yeah the voting
the jury pool yeah
are you ready to have your mind blown a
little bit though sure always you keep
saying the tournament last year
it was it was april of this year that we
did this last
okay well i mean it's not that
mind-blowing
it feels like it was forever at the
beginning of the year it just feels like
a diff because we were still in the
basement yeah
you know we didn't have i can't tell you
i can't say it blew my mind okay well as
you promised it would
i'll let you down yeah
you know
but it but you know
very cool fact
that's what i'm here for yeah cool facts
so be so basically we're going to get to
that after the break but we're all very
excited everybody in the audience is
going to get to participate we're going
to be doing the live
voting last year we did it on straw poll
we kept crashing their website and it
was a total uh crap crap show
so today we're actually youtube
implemented a voting system right here
in the chat
and we're gonna be using that that's
right so we shouldn't have any problems
that's right
oh man
that's right is that right
yeah so basically we want to talk about
a few things at the top of the show
before we get into the tournament
i'll show up first of all you guys i got
i got a real gripe
our freaking last episode from monday
after being up for a few hours gets
blocked by [ __ ] m
b
c
okay
now mbc is a korean media company
and you might be wondering what did they
block us for well let me show you and
this this is just
this is just agree this is unforgivable
these [ __ ] guys
used our clip you remember how they used
our
my modern art clip
and we were watching them react to it
they didn't ask permission to use my
clip i don't care you know use my clip
okay but when we watched the clip of
them reacting to us they blocked our
[ __ ] video worldwide
that ain't that some [ __ ]
ain't that some [ __ ] [ __ ]
i mean this is insane the copyright
system
is so [ __ ] and i keep telling youtube
you have to get rid of global blocking
you have to get rid of worldwide blocks
you know back in the day
you had to file a dmca takedown if you
wanted it to go down like that
which at least holds some legal
remedies to to me
but the worldwide block is just a tool
that youtube gives any media company
they can immediately remove your video
they don't have any legal liability
because the dmc is a legal notice
and
the most [ __ ] up thing about the
global worldwide block is that even if i
dispute it i say hey
this is fair use i'm putting my ass on
the line and i'm saying this is fair use
i can i can use this footage
let alone it being my own footage in
this case
this is my footage
uh i own this footage you know what i
mean
and so what happens is when these media
companies are worldwide block even after
i dispute it
the video stays down still for a week or
two
you can do nothing and when it's like a
new post i mean the damages are are
can be catastrophic you know your video
is being pushed out to the feed it's
being recommended
and basically stopping that
causes incredible damage to our business
and um
i mean it's just horrible for everyone
for people watching for us
you know if people do a dmca like
they're supposed to i can dispute it for
copyright and then it comes right back
up so what youtube is doing with these
global
worldwide blocks is they're basically
giving them
less legal liability
stronger tools to keep the video down
longer uh it is a [ __ ] cat it's a
catastrophe for creators the worldwide
block it really is
and you know like [ __ ] they're
using my clips i'm not going out
blocking people you know what i'm saying
like i could be i could do that to them
i could go block their [ __ ] video
i thought about it too i'll be honest i
was like i'm gonna block them [ __ ] them
i was so angry
that would have been funny but not the
right thing to do at first i was like
i'm gonna block them i'm gonna block
this [ __ ] video but it's not the
right thing to do
so what we ended up having to do is you
have to cut it out at least youtube
gives you that tools but why should i
have to cut out my own footage
so you cut it out and then it gets
restored so
you know and cutting it out takes like
12 hours yeah exactly it takes and
sometimes it doesn't even work like
recently
sometimes we'll try to cut it out
it just doesn't work and the video stays
down forever
there's an episode of i think after dark
from like two months ago
that
something like this happened we had to
cut something out and it glitched out so
bad that to this day the second half of
the episode the audio is like six
seconds out of sync with the video wow
there's no there's nothing you can do at
that point it's just it's just borked
forever
yeah so it's like well good for these
media companies that can just push a
button and [ __ ] my whole business up
but
i'm running a business here too and
there's got to be something i'm i'm
speaking with my lawyers about some
framework for holding people accountable
who just are going wild west with these
worldwide blocks there's got to be some
accountability
because these people are interfering
with my business they are not
considering fair use at all
uh and it's it's it's insane it's
absolutely [ __ ] so you know
there's got to be something to do and
the the pure irony about this too the
perfect timing of it
is that i was talking to my lawyer
yesterday like dude there's got to be
something we can do about there's got to
be some framework there's got to be
something we can figure out
well
just as we started thinking about that
guess who [ __ ] blocked
last week's after dark
at 1 30 a.m last night
this [ __ ] goon ryan kavanagh
worst dressed man in of the deck what in
the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] wearing
get the [ __ ] out so you know if you
didn't watch our last week's after dark
we watched a short clip of ryan
kavanaugh's boxing event which we're
like well you know we didn't even talk
about anything but ryan cavanaugh
aka the least interesting part of the
of the show
you know at least like with the current
copyright um
lawsuit they have against us they can be
like oh well you showed the heart of the
fight which was jake paul ben askren no
[ __ ] this is the if that's the
heart of the fight this is the uh
toenail of the fight
it's ryan kavanagh
dressed like a
eight-year-old who dressed himself
and exhibiting the personality of a
stale bread
and that's what we commented on and he
this guy probably drunk at 1 30 a.m
you know he's trying to edit my
wikipedia page it's not letting him
because it's locked and he's been banned
eight times
he's angry he doesn't know what to do he
can't drive anywhere because you know
his license doesn't work he needs his
driver to go anywhere
and so it's 1 8 1 30 a.m his driver's
unavailable
you know
you know what i when we were um putting
together the uh tournament yesterday it
it suddenly hit me as we were going
through all of these we don't have any
sound bites of ryan kavanagh and then it
occurred to me the reason is is even
though he's such a character on the show
and we [ __ ] hate him and we love
dunking on him
he is so
[ __ ] boring that
there's not there's gotta be something
we like we went through some we've gone
through we've looked it's just his voice
is like nyquil it just puts you to sleep
like immediately it's not funny he just
he sucks
that bad there is one we did find that
hit me with this it's actually pretty
good let's hear it this is the first
time
wow that that that is actually just
scary
that's like when the ghosts are speaking
to you through the radio signals yeah
murder
[Music]
[Laughter]
i do love when you guys cut it up it's
for him being saying something so yeah i
loved more of those i guess it takes a
lot of work though yeah whoever made
that shout out
play that again
this is the first time before me
oh my god
that's crazy
it's not like a speaking spell
yeah so he was sitting at home at 1 30
last night you know angry
and he's and he's like well
here they they watched they watched
this part and i can't sue them obviously
for this because this this this even i
can't even [ __ ] argue this one
uh
yeah what are you gonna argue this is
the heart of the event you [ __ ]
child
you
you
trust fun talentless baby you perpetual
failure you obsessed fan
you stalker i should get a restraining
order on you you stalker freak
here let me give you a tip if you want
your fight club to succeed stop trying
to beat dana white dude nobody wants to
see your pasty
[ __ ] crack her ass
and got him
honestly if anyone's a cracker it's it's
cat cat
yeah
i mean he's like you know how there's
people that are so white they're red
yeah he's red i mean
he's the embodiment of that price is
right fail sound
everywhere he goes
yeah if ryan wasn't wasn't using his
daddy's money i mean what would ryan be
doing for a living he'd be he'd be doing
more selling like uh
no offense to the profession but
he'd be a car salesman a used car
salesman he might be a mortgage broker
okay like a [ __ ] to your mortgage broker
at chase who like
who kind of lies to you and mislead you
a little bit
and you get into a whole [ __ ] thing
when the mortgage doesn't go through
because he lied to you
ryan you told me this thing was a sure
deal
listen i uh
you know
out of my control
[Music]
and by the way who wears tags to their
own event
lanyard energy
he's got lanyard energy for sure
yeah he is
laminated he looks like he's laminated
resting resting nicely between his [ __ ]
tits as uh alex jones would say
i bet he's got some big old giant [ __ ]
tits
do you possibly eat a lot of soy ryan
cavanaugh um slot of soy in your diet
yeah so he blocked it
[ __ ] love that eh
how good is that [ __ ]
fantastic
so i'm not sure what to do about that
because i'm not going to clip it so i
dispute it and well we'll see what
[ __ ] wants to do about that one
yeah
ryan kevin i've been off the rails
lately
he really been off the rails man
someone in the chat said he would have
been the type of guy that tells a woman
they need a new engine when they just
need an oil change
yeah
100
nailed it 100
handy handy
yeah but he's been totally off the rails
man he's not doing well you can tell
he posted he's been posting he's going
crazy on instagram dude
um
here let me just pull it up
you know he he he really is an obsessed
fan
um the [ __ ] he's been posting recently
and you guys know he's been getting his
posts removed for for community
guidelines strikes because he's been
like putting a bounty on my head and
[ __ ]
not to kill me but
for dirt
look at this one
idiot
fake nurse uses sister's license to get
work caring for kids lawsuit now he now
he's obsessed with this article about
the babysitter he refused to pay he's
posting or from 2016. i mean bro once
again wait till i read the description
though
once again [ __ ] you are failing to
acknowledge
that my ass
is literally just reading headlines
mother [ __ ] hollywood exact sued by
babysitter and wage spat what in the
gods [ __ ] ass do you want from me dude
what a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] dude
thank you hassan
is there a correction on this one here
before you sue me let's see is there a
correction or an update or something
there's a button to suggest a correction
well maybe you have a few suggestions of
some additional uh sure
ethan klein
[Laughter]
um
uh
i don't want to put my real music i want
people maybe we shouldn't do this
i was just going to type something that
i like hey maybe include that he also
got a dui hit and run
just
as how about that
atmospheric
thanks for the anyway
well they do say there was a correction
a previous version story misstated
ryan's title he is the founder and
former ceo of relativity media okay
important so once again bro what the
[ __ ] bro talk to fox uh what do you want
from me dude
anyway he goes
oh he he keeps tagging us too like he
talks about inciting harassment i mean
he blocks me and then he tags me in his
weird [ __ ] post thankfully he has no
fans
what are you talking about it's 5 000
likes
all organic every one of them
this is this comment is legit bro this
podcast in person should be banned from
any media gone too far seriously
account is private
he should be ashamed for what they've
done bottom of the barrel
private
[ __ ] them [ __ ]
let's see oh oh real person
okay
interesting
[ __ ] interesting let's investigate
this [ __ ] oh he's
oh it's the golden triangle guy
oh careful
um
interesting
well anyway there's only three comments
on it as far as i can tell so
i'm sure this dude is i'm sure this dude
really cares about the what's going on
let me read the description for you it's
a little menacing so of course he tags
us h3 podcast hd production next time
you accuse them of not paying their baby
nurse and encouraging teenagers to send
death threats on social media
[ __ ]
i have never encouraged in fact the
opposite is true i have never i've
discouraged i say people do not send
hate to ryan cavanaugh do not do
anything like that ever do you
understand what i'm saying
you tagging me though so of course i'm
gonna come read this i mean that's what
you wanted right you tagged me
he says
encouraging teenagers to send death
threats on social media if you're going
to make millions of dollars off your
fans oh so now all of a sudden i'm rich
because before i was a toy podcast
millions of dollars off your fans at
least be responsible and do research
they trust your word many high school
students in trouble because of your
podcast they blindly follow
some you got expelled from school
from you encouraging them to send
hostile messages okay first of all this
is just straight defamation i have never
encouraged anyone to send hostile
messages and anyone that does send
hostile messages is [ __ ]
super wrong
and i
think that you're a piece of [ __ ] okay
i'll just say that if you're sending
hostile messages to ryan if you're
sending death threats to ryan you know
[ __ ] you i mean ryan what do you want me
to do you cannot say i'm encouraging
people to send you threatening messages
you [ __ ]
i mean you're tagging me in this [ __ ]
so what does he mean he's getting people
expelled okay because this is real
interest oh have a new post from one
minute ago
this is big oh [ __ ]
yeah it's hot look at all we got one
like okay so we can watch we can watch
the bots roll in in real time actually
you can be the first to like that post
yeah i'll like it
now he'll just see one it'll be just me
and ryan
you should comment first
i don't think it will let me but i'll
try is those comments limited i would
just say hi ryan
this guy
is really
spending so much time obsessed with me
it's phenomenal
okay let's see if uh one minute ago
18 likes oh well the super troopers are
going to come in now but let's see it's
going to take a minute i think all the
sun is going to jump from like 10 to you
know 5 000.
you're such a [ __ ] thank you elo
yeah so i tweeted this out um i guess
here let's show this
this is exciting well here let me finish
this post
this is exciting this is real time beef
ryan if you're watching hi [ __ ]
you're a piece of [ __ ] dude
you're a piece of [ __ ]
you know and by the way ryan 1 30 p.m is
way too early to start drinking
like
you gotta wait longer bro put that drink
down i know you're drinking right now
it's five o'clock somewhere
yeah not where he lives
ryan's been telling himself it's five
o'clock somewhere for way too long
that's how you end up with a dui hit and
run yeah
you know what i mean i mean [ __ ] dude
alcohol ruins lives
so he says by the way what was this info
he says he's been getting our fans
expelled from school what does that mean
i assume that that post that we talked
about the other day of some idiot
messaging him saying he was going to
kill him or something he'd probably
report you know got a hold of the
authorities and got him expelled from
school
which yeah don't do that obviously i
mean look if you're sending death
threats and ryan goes out of his way to
uh call your school and get you in
trouble i mean
i guess you deserve it i don't know i
mean
don't do it ever ever do it yeah true
i mean i support you ryan go get people
expelled i don't know what the [ __ ] you
want from me
spend your day
carrying it up calling schools to get
stupid little [ __ ] teenagers expelled
that's awesome bro
they can't hear me because they're
listening to kids yeah i'm out here i'm
just listening to kids bopping your
asses your ass is full-time carrying it
up calling our
calling people's high schools to get him
expelled you weird creep
ryan i know you're watching put that
drink down
he's watching right now and he's sipping
i imagine he's sipping some
some whiskey on ice little canadian club
he's getting creeped out because i'm so
accurate he thinks he's looking behind
his back for a camera
that's the next instagram post ethan
klein put cameras in my living room
uh so he says the baby nurse in question
you accused me of not paying real
background fraud child endangerment
impersonation
and under criminal investigation for
extortion do we have you looked into
this what the [ __ ] is this about
i mean it's a case that's it started in
2016 it's still ongoing um
[Music]
i think it's going to trial next year
sometime but it has something to do with
uh the nurse
that's suing him
sister
and the nurse that's suing him is
part of the trial but
i i don't know i mean honestly i don't
know but the interesting detail about it
was that
the dispute that this article is written
in question about um
that nurse actually sued that family
first for unpaid wages
and then the family countersued for
other reasons and so it's a very like
messy complicated thing but i thought
that was interesting that uh he's also
being sued for a very similar reason
here in uh not paying not paying a uh uh
babysitter or
baby nurse i just want to just want to
shine real quick the the bots just
dropped on ryan kevin's post okay so 32
likes let's see
oh baby
here come the bots
the bots just drop
drop it like it's hot three comments
three co you know what's this what's
real interesting about this is that
he usually only gets 5 000 likes these
days i think he understands that when he
goes too far it looks obviously fake
right so he he limited it to like 5 000
bots so the fact that you're gonna get
all half of all the likes you're gonna
get on a post
in six minutes is pretty interesting
yeah
also this post is just weird like it
doesn't like if i saw this on instagram
i'd be like what am i looking at you
just scroll right past something weird
like this
like the guy doesn't know how to use
social media anyway this is pretty
exciting we got a live update from ryan
cavanaugh but
so again dude i'm just reading the
[ __ ]
article if you got a problem talk to fox
if you want them to do a correction talk
to fox okay [ __ ]
so he go he continues on
now here he makes the cardinal sin he
actually goes after ela and tags her
okay
now if you want to get angry that's
that's where we get angry
he says at eli klein also spoke out
against this as if she had info on
someone who worked with my child for two
weeks she is just as guilty oh [ __ ]
i don't even know what ela like barely
talked about it like dude why are you
going after my wife why are you going
after eli you absolute
freak show of a human being
maybe she should look
and who and what she endorses including
her husband
at h3 this guy loves tagging me
i stopped tagging him because i was like
ah maybe it's too much
but he got no problem with it talking
about sending hey
good thing bots don't cause much trouble
perhaps that would okay listen to this
including her husband perhaps that would
interfere with her rolls-royce and her
bell air mansion
um
it's your rolex voice first of all
but
like
so a few things are happening here it's
like okay so are you acknowledging that
like i have a serious show now
and that like i'm not a little toy bro
educated [ __ ] or right or and then the
other thing is like i know this it's
like public knowledge but i mean
it's kind of menacing to be like i know
what car you drive and where you live
yeah
comes off pretty much i don't talk about
where he lives or what car he drives
even though i could probably easily find
it well we do talk about what car he
drives which is none because he doesn't
have a license right
he doesn't try
he probably has a car but he's not
allowed to drive yeah yeah
haha [ __ ] i'm laughing cause you big
mad
he says perhaps that would interfere
with her so he's calling elo like a a
gold digger too kind of
he's attacking ela saying that would
interfere with her rolls royce in bel
air mansion um
my he's calling ela a gold digger okay
the rolls-royce is mine so if anyone's a
gold digger it's me because my wife is
[ __ ]
probably makes more money than i do i
mean we make everything together i you
don't know anything about true
partnerships
actually
not just in marriage but it seems like
in anything this guy doesn't like
partnerships
they are lucky i don't stoop to their
level as what's around them is dirt and
it's ugly yeah well when you when you
put a 25 000 bounty i'm sure whatever
you get is
super reputable what do you mean stoop
to their level you're [ __ ] posting and
tagging me every [ __ ] day and like
and like
worldwide blocking my videos what level
exactly do you have left you're suing me
three times
what left is down to stoop i don't
understand
says their schtick is amusing well thank
you
but once the stupidity wears off life
still stands and they're uneducated
ill-informed racist homophobic positions
permeate the youth oh he's concerned
about the [ __ ] corruption of youth
now
don't you run triller i mean like dude
that app is probably
i'm just saying apps like yours social
media apps you want to talk about
corrupting the youth i mean what the
[ __ ] you want to talk about some idiot
with a toy podcast
pretty sure your
position is not one
of authority on the matter
he says too far is too far
i don't know why he keeps calling me
uneducated i mean
i have a i mean
i have a
i have a bachelor's degree in english
literature i don't know
if that makes me like
ultra-educated uc i believe he went to
ucla right so i mean yeah we come from
the same kind of
instant school institution
yeah i don't i mean again i'm not like
that's not the only metric of education
obviously but i'm just saying
and i'll be the first one to say my
education wasn't great there but i mean
you know what i'm saying
i don't know why he says i'm uneducated
let's see where the likes are at on the
bot
okay
we're getting there
okay so [ __ ] all right here we go so the
new post this just dropped 11 minutes
ago
so i tweeted this lot you guys love this
i mean this is phenomenal
this guy is unraveling before our eyes
let me go to my twitter account so
last night i tweeted this when i
realized he blocked our off the rails
last week
so i said [ __ ] ryan kevin just
blocked our recent podcast worldwide
because he we made fun of his weird
outfit because there was a charisma of
steel bread [ __ ] you ryan cavanaugh
basically um and you know i posted a
picture
and i posted the uh
the worldwide block
um
that's it so let's see what he has to
say
uh he's tagged okay such a boomer he
tags us he tags instagram and twitter
like they're general
he he keeps doing that dude you know
that's not how it works right
and if any it's just so ironic because
he's the one that's getting community
strikes on instagram it's like why are
you trying to snitch tag dude like
you're the one doing the harassing
but why you can't snitch tag at
instagram like nobody really nobody is
going like you own triller
how dumb are you
do you read when people when people tag
at triller is that where you are you
just have a fee well maybe they don't
get that much that's what i was gonna
say yeah he can he can actually sift
through that yeah
okay so he says so when did making fun
of someone for their looks no way bro
you're really going for the bullying i
said your outfit is dumb well and also
you're ugly
i mean i don't i don't i don't care
making fun of your looks so what what do
you ate
no way he's taking the bowling approach
oh
[ __ ] stop it
he said
you're building someone stop it
since when did making fun this is too
good you guys i can't
i can't do this
since when did making fun of someone for
their looks
their intellectual capacity
and poking fun at them not only
acceptable but helps to generate
millions of dollars how am i
how am i generat he keeps saying i'm
generating money from this
how am i generating money from this i
mean i'm just doing my regular show yeah
i mean it's we're turning it into
content yeah but i'm saying it like i'm
just doing my regular show i'm not like
i mean the show has always been you
talking about what's
upsetting you with that particular yeah
i mean that's that's the context it's
not like he's giving i'm not it's not
like
he could drop the lawsuits and we would
stop talking about him
tomorrow
that's an easy solution i don't know if
you thought of that yet right i don't
know if i would i would be willing to
make that uh
i mean he'll become less relevant to me
i'm not gonna say but that's that's what
i mean but i'm just i'm not saying that
it would be like a uh well how often do
we talk quote a print quote a pr a pro
[Laughter]
i'm not willing to say that because i
mean how often do we talk about matt
haas on the show like never you know
what i mean yeah it's just less relevant
right but he's [ __ ] posting about me so
of course i'm gonna he tagged me for
christ's sake what am i supposed to do
yeah
this is amazing
so when did i make fun of him did i make
fun of his intellectual capacity i mean
i don't recall yes we've called him an
idiot many many times
didn't we find a tweet about him talking
about free speech
yeah he's like you can't call me stupid
your free speech stops when you call me
dumb
i'd say my outfit is funny
stupid [ __ ] dude ryan you are so dumb
you are such a [ __ ] stain on society
you're literally out here publicly
saying that you're making fun of me and
how is that okay
hello welcome to america
i think he's [ __ ] stupid i think ryan
cavanaugh thinks he's like a russian
oligarch where if you talk bad about him
like you get sent to the gulag
america [ __ ]
vladimir putin vlad you may be with your
best friends have led me out of food and
things would be different
i have never he says they're threatening
my family and friends harassing my
business partners
you got to stop saying that
at this point you got to stop saying
that okay
because now you're just defaming me
[ __ ]
buying are buying to build a website to
malign me well
yeah we did make a website not to malign
you though but
it was actually to help you out anything
yeah i think to help clear up some
misconceptions
yeah i mean let's see
he's referring of course to run if you
type ryan cavanaugh which i encourage
everyone to
do
um here it is does ryan kevin look like
harvey weinstein click this spend some
time on the website
click around read what we have i mean
it's to help him yeah do you see that
poll i mean
huge amount of do you see it yeah he
looks like harvey so we're basically
helping him
uh
people clarify that it's not harvey it's
actually a new person
named ryan kavanagh
he says threatening my family friends
and harassing my business partner buying
build a website to malign me spends
hours on his podcast youtube insta
twitter reddit and actually raising
money from teenagers
while doing it is allowed um
is he talking about like selling the
shirt selling merch probably
uh yeah probably i mean
normal business is normal business yeah
and
at the the team the zoomer that's not
our audience like he's just he's just
kind of wrong like i'm sure we have some
teenage audience out there but you know
our audiences not a bunch of teenagers
he goes surely the world hasn't gotten
this ugly [ __ ] i just listened
to the daily there's literally in
afghanistan right now millions of kids
starving to death
[Music]
but no ryan kavanaugh surely the world
hasn't gotten this ugly
dude this is not the worst thing
happening in the world right now i
guarantee it it might feel like that to
me and you
but you may want to [ __ ] read the
newspaper if you think this is where the
world has gone too far
um did you see this morning the the
little tidbit that i found in uh this
old new york post article about him no
i'd love to read it but let me check out
the co so elizabeth came out with the
banger first he allowed that one
interesting
uh h3 got karma coming their whole
platform is based off negative energy
and they don't have talent okay well
that's just your opinion emmanuel this
must be one of his fighters he's always
commenting he's always like one of the
five comments that's good i think she's
got loyal uh
he's got loyal peeps we'd like that you
know human followers i'm sure he i'm
sure he follows closely
you got i got no talent
and ryan cavanaugh does what's his
talent you've seen him try to hype up
his show
anyway show me show me what you got
there dan oh well so
i went down this whole rabbit hole
and there's this old new york post
article from 2009 about him from and
there was a few really funny little
tidbits in here first of all he at some
point around
uh 2009 launched a clothing line called
rogue hold on that's for anarchists in
his word yeah what because he's a rebel
anar bro you want your aunt on a kiss
you're complaining that i'm saying
naughty mean things about you
i yeah i didn't know uh ryan marcus is
an antifa uh hero but apparently he is
um
it it didn't do if if you could
if you could believe it it didn't do it
it didn't do that well here let me ask
you a question let me have as anything
ryan kavanaugh's ever done do well
um
on a long enough timeline
no and yeah
but check this out this was the real
thing that uh that got me laughing so
this was from [ __ ] 2009 right
sure
kavanaugh's personal life has also
helped fuel controversy in october he
was arrested for second time for driving
under the influence of alcohol while
still on probation for his first arrest
wow he said he intends to fight the
latest charges in many ways kavanaugh's
tinseltown trajectory mirrors that of
harvey weinstein
another maverick
whose astronomical initial success has
prompted nothing but uh shot and freud
there you go thank you yo
we gotta grab that quote and put it on
the website
the new york post ryan are you watching
this right now yeah it's funny i mean
this article is already talking pretty
negatively about him back in 2009 it was
his
his business lasted for several years
past that but um it seems like
the writing was already on the wall back
then you're used to being disgraced bro
like put just show the headline of that
one where it's like got the bust of him
that's crumbling like the crumbling
empire of ryan kevin we're still finding
[ __ ] about this guy like he is one of
the biggest degenerates
in the professional world
um
dude that love grab that quote we gotta
put that
maybe even the header of the website
yeah so this is from variety once again
relativity in ruins i mean this guy is
is used to
taking massive l's should we commission
a bus like that like a crumbling iron
kavanaugh
kind of epic i'm down actually
i'm kind of i kind of want that bust
yeah so i mean guys this is this is the
whole thing i think of him
what what ryan doesn't understand is i'm
just reacting to [ __ ] he's doing
you know he blocked our video
he should post and tagged us onto on
instagram
what do you want from me dude
i'm just [ __ ] defending myself and
responding to you let's get that quote
love at the top here
and just say and then just put like at
the
new york post or whatever it was
and a link to the article but yeah i
think that's a great header like
boom
all right sure yeah
i believe that's the second publication
that
related him to harvey weinstein
a lot of parallels apparently
yeah but they specifically said
mirroring
harvey weinstein too to
you know really drive home the
impression that they kind of look the
same
yeah because when you look in the mirror
what do you see right yourself your own
reflection
you know that's so interesting that
people have been drawing this comparison
before us
like a lot of people anyway um
by the way this is kind of funny too he
says comments limited due to hack by
trolls i still don't know what that
means
but okay whatever you say he was hacked
he's such a [ __ ] boomer he thinks
people talking [ __ ] to him in the
comments is is being hacked i'm being
hacked right now i'm under attack we
need the
homeland security to follow this up and
arrest ethan
emmanuel this is i don't think daddy
ryan is gonna give you a fight for this
comment by the way
he might he might be that petty anyway
um
listen
he's got to stop saying i'm telling
people to send death threats though
because that that is just not true
and it's actually defamatory you really
have to stop saying that ryan
um
that's really gotta stop that's [ __ ]
insane bro
okay
and um finally
on the topic of cavani kavanana cabanene
i wanted to give a shout out to this guy
i thought this video was [ __ ]
excellent
this lawyer called attorney tom
made a video about his recent lawsuit
about defamation
and it's really good analysis
it's a really really good analysis
and actually ryan threatened this guy or
he he do you
i don't have their interaction in the
document uh a b
i'll grab it i think we moved it one sec
yeah if you could just put that there
because
this guy made a comment like yo this
this new lawsuit against ethan
by ryan cavanaugh for defamation is
really dangerous stuff
uh and then ryan called him out
said he was like a paid chill working
for you yeah and then
attorney tom's like i don't even know
this guy bro
we only learned about attorney tom
because ryan kavanaugh was
accusing him of working for us
okay so basically
to second the records yeah so hold on i
gotta put this in order
where's his original post guys
ryan's are the attorneys the attorneys
oh it was a uh it was a comment post on
youtube like a community post no it was
a facebook post
uh or maybe a community post
post
yeah the top comment here is i do not
work for h3 i did not [ __ ] h3 i did not
put my dick anywhere near h3
so
um yeah he said
he goes
by the way
attorney tom literally was just said
like did the least thing and he goes
now he's promoting the law firm attorney
tom who is now acting like a
disinterested party
there are so many strings to pull and
this story will get more interesting
dude what are you are really drunk right
now
and then attorney tom has to record he
has to respond
i have never spoken with h3 i simply
made a video expressing my opinion about
ryan kavanaugh's defamation lawsuit
against him and now my professional
credibility is being questioned
again frank kavanaugh
free speech warrior
as i said in the video there's an open
invitation orion or any members of his
legal team to come on my channel for an
interview if they wish to discuss
vacation educate me
you know
what a [ __ ] psycho [ __ ] like you
really just threatening anybody that
supports me
i mean that's his goal right he doesn't
want people to support me
uh here is a brief excerpt.com reports
ryan kavanagh accused by ex-partner of
running a ponzi scheme that statement in
this article which is still published on
variety.com
is at the core of ryan kavanaugh's
defamation lawsuit against ethan klein
in today's video i'm going to go through
that lawsuit which brings up some very
interesting and scary legal concepts and
i'm going to be telling you why that if
you support independent youtubers in
free speech you should be rooting for
ethan klein
ryan cavanaugh is bringing this lawsuit
under two honestly it's a long video but
i thought the whole thing was super
insightful so i recommend checking out
attorney tom's video here i wish we had
time to watch i don't think anyone
really wants to sit through this whole
thing with me maybe they do i don't know
i thought it was awesome we got
a big tournament that we got to get to
today that's probably going to take a
good while so i don't know i don't know
if people want to watch this it is with
your pause rate that'll be like an hour
to get through let me watch like a
minute of it separate legal theories
defamation and defamation by implication
i'm going to discuss both starting with
defamation over the past few months
ethan klein has prominently displayed
variety's article about ryan kavanaugh
in the backdrop of his youtube set as
you can see here in ryan kavanaugh's
lawsuit here are screenshots of even
prominently displaying the variety
article not only is the article
prominently displayed but it has been
discussed multiple times dozens of times
i don't know if you heard that ryan
cavanaugh this man here was accused by
his ex-partner of running a ponzi scheme
so that's interesting yeah
awkward but anyway let me get actually
into this that was reported in variety
just for clarification
and even by ryan cavanaugh's own
admission via his lawsuit petition every
time ethan klein brought up the variety
article it was conditioned or predicated
on the sense that it was published by
variety and or it was his ex-partner
accusing ryan cavanaugh of running a
ponzi scheme yo this position is very
long and it contains tons of examples of
the alleged defamatory comments so i'm
just going to pick one read it and
you'll kind of get the point in july 15
2021 episode of off the rails titled i'm
sorry ela off the rails number five
which was v more than one point million
times klein said welcome back everyone
to the ryan cavanaugh accused by
ex-partner of running a ponzi scheme
podcast b ryan this is one from the
variety article over here and there
accused by ex-partner of running a ponzi
scheme which we've now clarified was
under oath not once did ethan klein and
his team ever say ryan kavanagh was
running a ponzi scheme they said
ryan kavanaugh accused by his
ex-partners of running a ponzi scheme
and that's an important difference i
would never at the california elements
for defamation one a false and
defamatory statement about another two
the unprivileged publication of the
statement to a third party anyway guys
you i watched all it's real good it's
really interesting and i thought you did
a great job shout out to tom tom who is
a uh working in the shadows uh he's a
shadow attorney
and tom if you're listening the checks
in the mail yeah check's in the mail
buddy we got you
yeah ryan cavanaugh's on he's pulling
the strings baby he's getting to the
heart of it
so
um we are
far over time to do our ad break all
right look we got two sponsors so thank
our sponsors and let's get right into
these action packed
sound bite tournament of champions gonna
be
and first i want to thank our wonderful
sponsor curology
love curology
you know it's a dermatology provider
service
you go online you take a survey you
answer a bunch of questions about your
skin
you send them close-up pictures of your
skin
so that a derm this dermatol dermatology
provider can assess
what you need and if it's a right fit
they'll send you a formulation
to treat
whatever's going on with your skin it's
a game changer
um
they'll create a custom prescription
cream for you for your specific goals
whether it's tackling acne clogged pores
skin texture dark spots fine lines or
something else
you start by taking a short online skin
quiz
and uploading photos and if it's a good
fit they'll ship you your formula right
to your door
and it's even got your name on the
bottle so how it worked for me is i did
the quiz i sent the photos and they sent
me three products they sent me a
cleanser
which i love
doesn't strip my skin of all the natural
oils and make it super dry
then so you wash you put on the cream
formula and then you put on the
moisturizer and it's all super high
quality stuff you know comes from this
dermatology provider
and my skin feels great it's never felt
better you don't have to fretz around
with the dermatologist
you don't have to go to the office you
don't have these huge fees i mean
dermatology is expensive man
it's an awesome service super recommend
it get started with curology like i did
with a free 30-day tryout at
curology.com h3 just pay five bucks for
shipping and handling that's
c-u-r-o-l-o-g-y
dot com slash h3 to start your free
30-day trial you can cancel any time
and the prescriptions are subject to
consultation thank you thank you to
curology
and finally i thank you to upstart
upstart
what would you do if you didn't have
high interest loans or credit card debt
with upstart you can pay off your
existing debt quickly and easily and
start living your life
upstart is the fast and easy way to pay
off your debt with a personal loan all
online whether it's paying off credit
cards consolidating high interest debt
or funding personal expenses over a
million people have used upstart to get
one fixed monthly payment with a clear
payoff date
rather than looking at credit scores
alone upstart considers other factors
like your income current employment and
credit history to find you a smarter
rate for your loans you can check your
rate without impacting your credit score
to within minutes for loans between one
thousand to fifty thousand dollars you
can even receive funds as fast as one
business day after accepting your loan
so find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today when you go to
upstart.com h3 that's upstart.com
h3 don't forget to use our url to let
them know we sent you loan amounts will
be determined based on credit income and
certain other information provided in
your loan application that's upstart.com
h3 thank you
all right
[Music]
so
here we go
oh by the way people were saying they
wanted to do a pull of our age breakdown
because
frank kavanaugh seems to think that all
of our audience are like 15.
and i know that's not true we should do
we should do a
let's start off our poll let's test our
poll here we're gonna be doing lots of
polls today
let's set up some age brackets so i
believe it restricts you to four yeah
four options so maybe 17 and under
18 24
yeah 25 to 30 and then 30 plus or 31
plus great that sounds perfect 17 or
under
18 to 24
25 to 30
or 31
plus
i i'm assuming it's the community i'm
assuming that they're mostly probably
you know mid-20s
i think that's
where
the bell curve will be
let's see i'm real curious
is there a way to show this poll on
screen you know because like on straw
poll we were able to
the audience can see the vote
yeah there's not it doesn't let you pop
it out i mean see that's a problem i
think for for the show visually
uh you know what i might have a way
so basically the votes are coming in i
mean
it's a little primitive but
because you can see the chat but it was
better i think the other way
where you had it if you minimize it it
shows more of the pull
are now only showing the winner
yeah
can you see that ian like is that can
you guys make that out is that good for
me why you got to do that because
it needs to be full screen there's a
reason i did it here i'll make it bigger
okay there you go that's awesome
so yeah it looks 18 to 24 is about half
and then
20. so you can see that 17 and under is
by far the smallest demographic yeah
so cav cavs teenage teenager conspiracy
does not
chip past the vibe check
sorry we love our our
we have such a mature audience folks
don't we i mean
we are adults
and we don't send death threats right
folks no
of course not
no no true fan
whatever
you're saying it's a school day you
think that there's like well we're
always on school days when are we never
on school yeah but like right now you
think that the teenagers are voting kids
are in class but also
maybe they're not so
i think there is a lot of kids in class
voting on that poll to be honest with
you
or t or you know call our
students let's say that's true
well
let's get it let's kick it off man this
is okay so
we're gonna start
let me familiarize myself with
everything here
i'm gonna click this i've got a lot to
navigate here let me open my docs okay
so we've got basically how this works
is we watch the origin the first round
is going to be lots of origin story
and then
the next brackets are going to go pretty
fast
so here up first is the
world champion of 2020
the undisputed sound by king of the
world
david
guter in the wake of the tragic death of
george floyd
made a stand he he he made a beautiful
tribute to george and his family
this racism stops now he said
and this beautiful tribute
lives forever it is
in honor of george floyd
and i really hope we can see more
unity and more peace
when already things are so difficult
so
shout out to his family
and that
and that's when aces race
yeah so you know and that's when racism
ended my friends it's over
so when you hear conservative are you
when you hear like psycho right when
conservatives say racism doesn't exist
anymore well they're right and it
happened since since uh
david took this right exactly
shout out to his family yeah so there's
a soundbite it's yeah
all right so that's our first
our first bracket
and he's up against
wendy williams just saying that's that's
good
now what are these this isn't so so
here's what we've done there are certain
sound bites that always come together on
the show like they're always kind of
played
you know one after the other or
something um so in those cases instead
of just picking one which we felt would
be unfair because it doesn't really give
the totality of the drops as they're
used we we kind of cluster them together
so
this is an example of that um death to
all of them and her talking about making
people suffer so you're doing basically
wendy williams as a single contestant
here yeah and in some cases it's like
it it's not just wendy williams although
i think this might be her only entry on
the bracket is that right well yeah
yeah wendy williams farting sounds would
not be grouped with this like this is
wendy williams
threatening to kill people well we're i
don't see the just saying here i see
clap if she should suffer which i'll
play here
like the original one that's on the
bracket isn't here but here let's listen
to this one
should she suffer
all right clap if you think she should
suffer
yeah so that's wendy
fantastic
that was weird wasn't that ryan
cavanaugh behind her
should she suffer what why is she
talking about ryan kavanagh all right
yeah that's weird she's following the
suit
oh well this is from 20 this is old yes
she was following the suit weird
last year two years examine a little bit
more
i think that's actually harvey weinstein
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
[ __ ]
damn
so that's that one
and then there's also the death to all
of them iconic obviously
how dare you mr spears you had me fooled
and you too mrs spears death to all of
them
she shocks i mean and you know she
shocks herself and the audience everyone
is just
she went full isis on that mother
you know where's the worst the original
one so there there's two we we couldn't
really find just saying
i guess we could plan we'll play it yeah
let's hear it just saying just saying
yeah so
okay
you get we found them for the most part
uh there was like one that one and one
other one though kenneth copeland oh one
of the kenneth copeland ones it was like
a total deep cut yeah
all right well you've got wendy williams
just saying
which has become you know widely used
it's it's a great sound drop but the
competition is stiff i mean she's going
against the world champ i don't know go
ahead with the poll let's see what
happens you want to go for it yeah of
course okay also we've prepared um
a little timer
um
for these votes so that you know
we have a cutoff point of um
well it seems pretty
obvious uh so
shout out to his family
just saying slash
uh death to all of them
all right here we go with round one
i can't see on my screen here on the
right dan i don't know why that one do
you need that one on the right
uh yes
okay that's the bracket
[Music]
so here we go
yeah this i think we're in for a
surprise here i mean shout out to the
family is an oldie
it has been around for a while it's very
good though
that's it
the king is dead i mean that's it
you're not even gonna wait you're gonna
i mean dude that that's i mean that's a
pretty it's a blow up that's a blow out
and you know
that's a blowout and i gotta say i agree
i think wendy took this year with the
sound bites go ahead play them all zach
die i mean die
wendy
wendy is just too good the st the [ __ ]
that comes out of that woman's mouth
is truly
shocking and vile i mean
if anyone should be giving a
a
eulogy for george floyd it would be
uh wendy williams what would william
what would want
very tactful very respectful to all of
them yeah she would be like that and be
like whoa
just saying we're at a funeral
they are iconic drops okay well uh yeah
you're right that's a that's a blowout
well i think if anything it just shows
this is a new year there's new
competitors and there is going to be a
new king on the block this year the
verified winner is wendy williams by a
landslide
and dare i say possibly a favorite to
take the whole tournament i think yeah
it's got a good chance it's got a good
chance i mean just saying a lot of
banners in this competition though just
okay well let's move on to the next
round
we'll see you know all right so up next
we've got um
okay i've been listening to olivia the
entire time
the ominous
threatening spooky
uh our beloved uh olivia one of my
favorites i gotta say it is i've been
saying it around the office constantly
it's so catchy
wait hold on ian aren't you showing on
dan's computer do you you need me to
zoom in on the bracket
because why don't you just show
what i've got and then you can click
this is good just like this yeah
why do you need it open on your screen
dan
because okay
i guess i don't
yeah because if you want to show me some
well just choose which one you want to
do
well i have to put the poll up on the
screen anyways just just use mine yeah
just mine yeah thank you
so
basically we've got this one here
the custody of her beautiful daughter
olivia
who is here also right now with mom
and ashley
olivia is that olivia i had a feeling
that was illegal i've been listening to
olivia the entire time
why does he say it like that
i have never actually seen that it's
like creepy like people make fun of joe
biden being creepy how you like touch
hair and [ __ ] and whisper in ears
this imagine whispering that in your ear
and ashley look how sweaty his face is
olivia are we going to talk about the
fact that he said ashley and then olivia
that's crazy oh my god
that was
crazy that nick was sick calling you
ashley yeah i'm also ashley [ __ ] olivia
trump is playing 5d traps wow how did
you find this one zach so this was
actually submitted by one of our mods
blizzard woofie wow
i love that man this is a good
find yes
i'm so jealous they'll never be in
donald trump a b sound bite everyone
else got one
has he ever said a baby
yeah don't say that somebody can figure
it out ask me the baby hey baby hey baby
what is there an ethan one jack
yeah there's a ether ethan oh yeah ethan
ethan
there won't be a loved one
don't say that guys one don't say that
the right context
but i think this
i think you should probably group all of
the them in with this one so why don't
you play
all of the names uh trump sound bites
we've got zach okay one second
so
dan please stand up ethan please stand
up zach please stand up
we have please stand up as a different
one oh we do in the bracket okay all
right well no okay all right well anyway
we've got olivia uh we've been listening
to olivia the entire time bolivia and of
course a new and very powerful entry
this one
is strong the quartering um who famously
peed
in his basement wow because his wife
went for pizza without him no
i'm not taking
this this uh clip is the original but
the one that we've nominated is actually
one of the updated ones that includes uh
imagine the the mashup with all right
well let's play the original yeah but
this is taking a pause to pee
yeah so he says i'm not gonna pause my
game to pee i'm just gonna pee right
here as any thoughtful well-adjusted
adult does
clearly
and um well we made a mashup
of him
taking a [ __ ] of him telling a story
where he [ __ ] his pants zach go ahead
with that one i'm not taking a pause to
[ __ ] all over the floor
it gets me every time
that's good
all right well let's do a pull we've got
the quartering [ __ ] on the floor
versus donald trump
uh naming people
this is a tough one i mean i feel like
these are both kind of deep cuts
you know they're they're very they're
good in particular moments
you know all right polls going up
but i don't know if these are
well i it's hard to say i mean the the
quartering one is q it always makes me
laugh
it's a classic
trump okay
oh wow yeah well trump is taking the
huge dub trump taking the dub his first
one hold on there's only a thousand
votes and let's let's give it a moment
one more time but yeah the first oh wow
there you go
like kavanaugh's bots the votes are
rolling in
yeah
three two one
we're calling it
okay enough okay wow the the quartering
just uh
sorry he didn't want that title this
year
wow well congratulations olivia how do
you feel good
i why is my voted for myself
so what is happening here you voted for
yourself i did
all right
i've been listening to olivia the entire
time advancing to the next round
fantastic
it's just so clean yeah no it's great i
love it fantastic shout out i've been
listening to olivia thank you zach
so okay good
um
moving on we've got keemstar
let's see
of course this was a new one we
discovered of a keemstar deep cut
actually okay so this this is a mega
compilation i guess of keemstar ones
because there's just too many i guess
actually there isn't one that stands on
its own
it's a little confusing guys to have
like three together
and then one by itself i have to say
let's just do this one keemstar shut up
[ __ ] um
this was a deep cut i don't know what
this is from keemstar used to be up to
some weird [ __ ]
and it was run by this like eccentric
rich guy who like all of us hate games
and keemstar was trying to chime in and
alki david i guess his name is
keemstar shut up
keemstar knows i'm gonna win shut up
[ __ ] because
and he shuts up real fast i don't know
who this guy is but
he really uh put keemstar in his place
and we love that for him
and this one gets a lot of play
obviously keemstar shut up [ __ ]
and it's it's tremendous i mean this is
a sound bite that i really appreciate
shut up [ __ ] yeah just nice to see him
put in this place you know anytime he's
talking
here's a here's a few other honorable
mentions
i
have been caught in 4k i'm busted
what was this one he got caught he was
wrong about something he said about me
so frustrated i'm pretty sure it was
about me history of truth was playing
this clip of me saying duck to all jews
like he had this oh and he said that we
faked it right he said that we edited it
yeah we were right i was like i didn't
[ __ ] yeah and so then he found out he
did actually say death to all jews oh
natural
yeah i so have been caught so
frustrating i'm busted
it's so frustrating
yeah well you said it so
[ __ ] i don't know what to tell you
bro
and then of course another honorable
mention is uh
murder animals
let me get this straight y'all exposing
trisha paytas for having
rabbit fur chairs right and i bring up
the point saying well uh how can didn't
call her out for murdering the chickens
when she was eating the chicken sandwich
murdering the cows when she's eating the
hamburgers how many didn't call her out
then huh huh huh and you say oh well
it's a difference one you use for
substance you know energy for your body
and the other one she just murdered it
for a chair okay [ __ ]
okay [ __ ] you're really gonna reply to
me on a [ __ ] cellular device on a
[ __ ] laptop or a cell phone hmm the
lithium batteries inside those where do
they get those oh they get those um out
there and they have to mine and then
destroy forest and murder animals for it
you stupid [ __ ] everything you do
he's so unlucky
i get why him and ryan kavanagh get
along on the road stupid [ __ ]
gas in there they have to [ __ ] mind
that they have to pull that out of the
[ __ ] ground guess what who dies
animals die
all right like dude the forests that are
being destroyed animals are being died
for you to just exist
that you live in so when you're sitting
there [ __ ] chirping right oh my god
she murdered rabbits for chairs
dumb people are like yeah she murdered
rabbits for chairs smart people are like
well pretty much everything you do in
your [ __ ] life you know you're
murdering animals for
stupid [ __ ]
that's uh that's been a
wait what does he say at the end i
remember it was funny he goes stupid
[ __ ] [ __ ] murder a murderer
yeah so play all the sound bites
yeah
so that video alone was basically the
giving tree of keemstar sound bites we
calling this one wait what are you why
are you running the poll already because
it takes a while for it to show up on
stream for some people i didn't even
play the next one yet oh my bad
keemstar spazzing versus
the vin diesel
family oh this is a dark horse
this is a dark horse i think this one's
going far this is one that you know
made a
recent
addition to the catalog of sound bites
it's kind of taken
and actually
family family family family family
family family family family family
family family family family family
family family family family family they
don't stop they didn't stop dude
this was a late addition that has really
taken the community
our whole chat by storm
it's just nothing but families right now
that so i mean
wow
this is stiff competition out here this
year
well go ahead with the vote i mean yeah
it's a tough one because this is a tough
one keemstar is obviously those are
fantastic sound bites yeah um
[Laughter]
but damn if it that if that family one
isn't powerful
so get those votes in
holy [ __ ] no way
oh i don't know about this it looks like
keems is rigged
right having us bots are in here [ __ ]
up our tournament
well that's like a blowout and i gotta
say i mean i love those keemsta that
shut up [ __ ] one is so good
but i thought the family would take it
but no
this is a huge upset in my opinion i
agree with you on that i mean it's it's
relatively i mean
60 40 you know that's a blowout i mean i
remember we did this last year a lot of
them were real close but this is like a
clear win i mean i don't know what to
say this is a clear win i'm a little
upset
a little bit devastating
i don't think so i think the people have
spoken
and rigged shut up [ __ ] is so good
yeah i think we're confusing like the
meme with the sound bite like the sound
bite itself i say keemstar all day we
love our family true that's true i mean
that's that's a fair point we have to
bear in mind
i don't know though i'm surprised by
this i feel like he could use the family
in any context you know should we do it
again should we do a revolt should we do
like
that would be wrong i think you should
get one silver bullet if you don't agree
with a vote what is it you get one thing
to bring back if you don't think that it
was voted on correctly i mean it got
[ __ ] clowned by yeah i mean it's not
even close
let's do a revolt like florida hanging
chads and [ __ ]
i mean you're
you're
you're doing it you're convincing
everybody to vote a different way i mean
it's not it's not fair it's last year
all over again yeah giving keem what he
wants it's almost 20 000 votes and why i
mean the family one
i i i'm sorry i think the keem ones are
way [ __ ] better
yeah i thought everybody was agreeing
that no i mean most everybody is but i
disagree no i'm the key drops are
amazing yeah him screaming murder
animals murder animals here's it again
give it to give it to me
all right i mean come on and another
thing is just zach's timing with them
are always so good like it's so good his
timing with that backs me up every time
yeah i mean that one video alone did so
much for the soundbyte community it
really did it really is just incredible
and the families is a is a nice meme but
okay i think it's a dub for for keemstar
shut up [ __ ] all right i mean
congratulations every word he says in
that video is somebody yeah the
percentage really isn't i mean it's not
moving we're almost twenty thousand
votes yeah it's still sixty forty so wow
okay well the people have spoken all
right
i guess if it was closer we could do a
reason sure but that's a blowout yeah
that's a blowout what's the you know in
a real election if it's within what
percentage it's got to be like a half a
percent oh is it that small yeah it's
gotta be really tight margin or maybe
five percent five percent percent how
about let's do five percent if it's
within five percent we can call a
recount okay
five differences astronauts exactly all
right so that's right so star is
spazzing is moving on
to the next round star star
wow this is shaping up to be quite a
tournament this year
so moving on to the next bracket here
we've got
the marvel mashups basically if you guys
aren't familiar marvel has been putting
out these marketing stings
where the audio editing is such a
[ __ ] train wreck
where they've just mingled and
frankenstein the audio that it just
comes out it's so funny here listen this
is the one that bursts at all and this
is the first time for me in the marvel
universe
yeah so this actually turned in this was
blowing up on the internet i mean this
has 1.2 million views yeah this is the
first time for me in the mar so we say
that all the time in the office yeah
i say all the time at home i can't stop
saying that sound bite but also birth
the new meme like play the ryan
cavanaugh one i mean it's always this is
the first time for me eating uh carl's
jr whatever first time for me
yeah
beautiful the symphony it's so fun but
apparently their audio engineer uh
has done a lot of work for the
for the uh
he's done some editing work for disney
plus for example listen this one
there's a hunger for this character to
come back
that one is really good that one is
really good
there is a hunger for
pizza
you know dan
dan said the word funger he was trying
to say finger a few episodes ago so i
edited something
uh does it sound like it there's a
finger before this character who comes
back
well done zach that's great thank you um
and then of course
shang chi the same audio engineer struck
again
hi my name is aquafina and i am in the
movie
no that's probably the worst i don't
know like i think the first is
yeah
so that's basically the whole genre of
terrible marvel
audio engineering
and we're up against
love our very own love
who basically there was an attempted
assassination of love bot by a b
never forget oh we don't
i do not know what's happening it's
wrong over there without the event
jesus
not one of you guys could have caught
that what happened i didn't even see it
happening until it hit it dude it's like
evie did that everyone saw that
and and we did you know we went back
if you check the footage
when you give him a little push he
usually will just roll back and i was
rolling him back give me a push mom i
was i was giving him a push because
there's a little divider between us and
i honestly was afraid he was going to
fall and i gave it too hard of a push oh
yeah you i mean that's that's an
assassination attempt look at that look
those are brand new headphones i just
threw off to try and save him well that
was a brand new love boat and look at me
now man come on dude
you can't even vote
was new for like six hours
see there's still fightings they're
fighting words no no we're on the same
team now all right well i'm starting the
poll so that yeah so we've got basically
the attempted assassination of love bot
versus uh marvel audio engineering this
one could go either way honestly i'm not
quite sure i mean
both are good for this character to come
back
which one is more versatile i think the
marvel one is
i don't know let's go marvel once i
can't see the vote the marvel one's
pretty niche well i didn't want to
reveal yet well i want to see the voting
take place okay
we got another blow up probably the
biggest blowout yet wow
[Music]
thank you youngs it's equalizing a
little bit as the votes come in but i
don't think the scuffed edits are going
to overtake that lead wow
wow i'm honored guys thank you
wow how do you feel love i mean that is
a
that's a huge win that's a huge dub and
against a really formidable competitor
as well
yeah
i feel
like over
overwhelmed honestly this is crazy 61-40
that's crazy
well let's see in the next bracket
you're actually going to be facing
keemstar being told to shut up so
how are you feeling in the next bracket
are you feeling confident yeah i'm not
feeling confident well maybe i don't
know if the lovebot seems it's going to
pull through maybe maybe not we'll see
okay
well congratulations rob thank you yeah
i'm i'm glad to have come this far and
we we all did see that by the way we did
also i'm even honored to be to be
included absolutely thank you thinks the
way he says aby that makes it so good
like the uh
all right we have the winner love av did
that everyone saw that there it is
can someone grab me a saudi please
sure
and also like a pizza or burrito or
sandwich or something
oh do you want the rest of my breakfast
burrito
oh for real yeah
if you actually want it you ate half of
it yeah let me see the let me examine
the situation
let me see what's the damage
[Music]
bring the burrito over here
thank you all right let's see so this is
olivia's burrito what kind of burrito is
this olivia bacon breakfast okay i like
that
now obviously i don't i'm not gonna eat
from the eat-in part
i mean should i eat it backwards
you cannot
i mean it's totally your choice
how you choose to eat that i don't want
them
right right
we are in a pandemic
how is it
don't look at me like that dad it's good
right it's i'm not looking like anything
look at it
i wasn't looking like anything i'm just
you're looking at me like this
that's just
my resting [ __ ] face oh my god good
you just think i'm judging you anytime
you're eating
you're reading into it no you are
all right
okay
next up oh next round is a doozy
next round's a doozy this one is you
know
strong competitor
i dropped this soundbite
when trisha was talking about something
i don't remember what
but it was an iconic moment
shut up [ __ ]
and my god i've never heard it said with
such gusto such passion the rock has an
absolute talent for saying shut up [ __ ]
absolutely it's
so good
that is such a good sound bite
one of my proudest moments even i would
don't say it you don't want to admit
that bro
people got real mad at you for that too
late
rip rip to the goat my dude
yeah you can't take that back
um
here it is full screen it it's full
screen gg
really good maybe
wait it's not that it doesn't seem long
enough like we reflected on it for a
while didn't we
okay let's go it's almost two minutes
long okay go ahead
and it felt really good and i think
people obviously people liked that so
much more i saw a tick tock of this
amazing artist named inky which i
actually met her idolically [ __ ]
jesus what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
ah
that was so inappropriate yeah we cut it
out because we're like this is too
[ __ ] up but then
we all it was just the funniest thing
one of the funniest things ever happened
on the show
that we showed it later on so that's
kind of the history
the sound bite definitely makes its
rounds to this day
and um
so what is what is he up against
um
we've got shut up [ __ ]
versus you don't even have to think
about it dude
crowder making fun of me incidentally
became a sound by himself yep you're a
governmental body with scientists and
[ __ ] they just tell us what to do you
don't have to think about it dude
[Laughter]
after dark
seriously they're just telling you you
don't have to think about it dude by the
way
my my rule is right whatever we say
always just extend the context a minute
in either direction it only gets worse
like
rogan's so stupid why is he questioning
uh any like the cdc or fouchy yeah
seriously bro you're not a doctor i
don't even know i don't want to think
about things
[Music]
tell me and we just went through without
you how he went from it occurred anyway
shut the [ __ ] up crowder yeah i mean
just got banned this morning he just got
banned again for more hate speech like
how much hate speech youtube
you can you're like 10th hate speech
yeah wow what a [ __ ] nightmare
bro you're such a piece of [ __ ] shut up
anyway something stupid bro
well anyway we make great use so that
you don't have to think about it yeah
very versatile during copy reads yes
right yes they even have to think about
it all right so i'm gonna i'm gonna
launch the poll right now yeah go ahead
so you know two strong competitors
yeah i think crowder's got an uphill
battle here but but we'll see
i mean that's my hunch
as well
i mean crowder was a participant
wow
all right hold on only only 1500 votes
but obviously yeah
there's a
strong lead here i think we may have
accidentally skewed the results again
that's what i was afraid of
but i don't think crowd ever had a
chance anyway yeah true
again shut up [ __ ]
but yeah i mean
shut up [ __ ] is so good
all right seventy seven thousand
that's a nine it's dipping but yeah it's
close to ninety percent
[Music]
you can call it yeah
i think we're calling it there
that's by far the biggest blowout i mean
that's a that's almost 90 percent win to
shut up [ __ ]
all right so the rock congratulations
shut up [ __ ]
crowder shut the [ __ ] up [ __ ] and even
without the trisha context i mean you
you're afraid that's what's skewing it
a.b
potentially because it's just such
everyone loves that moment but that's
not skewing it because that was
that was the origin story just like any
other organization i do think we need to
make a statement that
you should try
like an impartial jury
to separate
the sound bite from the moment
[Music]
oh my god all the people saying no pull
it works fine it's on your end shut up
shut up
these are these are
shut up [ __ ] shut up [ __ ] shut up
these are our members we love them we
have tens of thousands of votes coming
in it's it's the polls working fine it's
it's you
whatever it is it's working better than
straw poll yep
your vote wasn't tipping the results in
that one anyways then 90 90 percent
shut up [ __ ] thank you olivia i did it
all right
you ate it all even the part that she
touched i did oh
sorry you don't have soldering man
promise
i was boosted last week
dude i was boosted yesterday i'm dying
my wi-fi is off how weird
now it's back on
so
honestly looking at this so far
the rock is going to be a strong
contender yeah i think so
going down
we've got
copelan
and kenneth copeland
the demon stuffed into human skin
go ahead we don't have a source for this
one so just go ahead and play it
do you see it
you have any other copeland ones you
want to group in there yeah i mean i i
have a [ __ ] ton
i get that can i get that spear zack
watch a demon die
from death to life
kenneth copeland's a evangelic evan
gelatist
speared
one of these psycho prosperity preachers
who is
ultra rich off the backs of poor
working class uh conservative christians
he is evil
he is scary he is psycho psychopathic
and the fact that someone like this can
even be successful in this world is
proof that
uh evil does exist in this world oh
jesus
if anything he's proving satan exists
the the uh ha ha you see it uh really
came prominent with the uh
harvey cav
[ __ ]
yeah
do you see it when you're comparing that
yeah right right some beautiful timing
on those zach yeah thank you yeah the
utility of the do you see it is
incredible so we've got basically the
copeland uh mega pack
copeland mega pack amen and up against
it is my own mother donna clyde
with dubrick um she doesn't want to say
david dolbrick
fantastically here do you want to try
the white claw gabe well you know i
don't
[ __ ] baby [ __ ] it's friday [ __ ] baby
[ __ ] yeah yeah very good oh that's my
mom doing what club gabe yes it's a
there's a
another little twofer so then this is
the the dubric one here
first names or name of the youtube
channel i'm giving even giving you a
hint are you you know what i have no i
wait a minute the guy on the left
that is that david uh dubrick
no he's not it is not okay do you want
to i don't know why it's so funny
you can't hint if you
dubrick is so good
the way she says it and the fact that
she's wrong anyways
whenever we talk about it i mean you say
dubrick yeah yeah
dubrick
so basically we've got um
the donna clown copeland versus dubrick
so
all right so i'm going to let's see that
[Music]
copeland versus dubrick
that's a toughy
[Music]
hmm
oh wow oh oh wow that's a blowout i am
blown away at this
really i mean nobody cares about
copeland no i love
i love donna but
by far out of any soundbites on the show
kenneth copeland kills me
i don't know why he's my favorite i'm
not super i'm surprised that that my
mom's winning by such a margin but
i get it i mean dubrick
i mean also you're dude you've got the
don arks in this yeah that's right
they're voting for the person not the
sound of you you're going oh we got the
don arcs out there
copeland's angry he's not happy about
these results
that's good
he's not happy there's just you know i
love donna full down arc but the kenneth
ones are they're they're probably one of
my personal favorites
i just love when you do that do you see
it when ethan's like zooming in on
something funny on that he spotted in a
video or something it's just it's just
got such a utility yeah it's very very a
lot of them have a lot of utility but
there you go the people have spoken
donald so monarchs are out in force
dubrick
dubrick let me see if my tick tock
posted
some people in the chat saying they
couldn't see it yeah because it because
tick tock is
let's see oh it's up now what's up do
you see it yeah they don't post [ __ ]
right away they just uh
because my account is like on the
[ __ ] [ __ ] list because i get so many
videos removed they hold all yours for
review yeah they have to review it first
but it looks like it passed all right
for now anyway yeah
so it's up
oh my god it feels so good to say that
i was like oh my god please god let me
say something about this
i was like i'll just wait till the
wedding's over
all right well donna is the clear winner
here so donna
takes the dub by the way the monarchs
are flourishing this year so
it's the year of the monarch for sure
all right up next
donna klein here we go this one's a deep
cut i mean okay
let's see this is of course comes from
the prince family someone that we've
content courted
what's good youtube you already know
what it is
the most annoying intro
[Laughter]
of all time you're gonna love this i
think i might have found
because i couldn't find the specific one
that the zac sound drop comes from
because they do it in every video but i
found
maybe the worst one okay great well here
it is
can you do me a favor
play the one guy who's crying for his
son where he goes i still love you and
he goes
you have that one play that and i'll
play hers
okay here we go wait hold on wait wait
wait wait youtube you already know what
it
is let's see how that syncs up
pretty good
it's
and we are great once again guys
yeah i think they need to do that again
with more energy
so that's bianca
they're the ones that like click bait
their kids dying and [ __ ] right or
like not even like having horrible
like skin diseases yeah i just sent my
favorite thumbnail of theirs if you want
to yeah the prince family is some
youtube legends oh she fell
they're like my
kids yeah this is a recent one i mean
this one's this one's silly but it's not
as bad because like the other ones was
like my kids have got leprosy and it's
that one like boils all over their face
in the [ __ ] thumbnail i mean jesus
christ
so we got bianca up okay well yeah i
mean you've got in a book hump from
keemstar
in a book and i'm sorry but
i don't know man in a book is really
good billions off his photos what fake
doodle tweeted out for proof context
showing that he used to take pictures of
charlie demilio for instagram oh okay
and it was used in a book huh they did a
little set laughing
i'm pretty sure he's got the same uh
audio editor as marvel
yeah
a lot of proof guys
showing what the [ __ ] is this used to
take pictures of charlie demilio for her
instagram oh okay
and it was used in a book huh they do
dude
what who first of all drop a dislike for
keem
first of all
it goes watch this lawsuit says on the
bottom left
shared feedback with creator okay thanks
thanks for letting him know i don't like
his video
yeah so i don't know what he was
thinking but it has served us well
we know keemstar doesn't know how to
read
so that's why he's so confused
about the notion of a book well anyway
let's
let's to put these two uh against each
other shall we we shall the poll
is being issued
right
now
bianca verse in a book huh yeah that's
kind of what i expected
another
big blowout that that's actually maybe
our biggest blowout
93
in a book i mean
is
real solid i dare i say
don't say it
go ahead say it i think it might
i don't necessarily think it'll win but
i think it's going to go far that's what
i'll say i think i think in a bookcon is
going places huh
animals die
okay well stupid [ __ ]
all right well that's it that's that's
an easy that's uh
oh wow wow wow wow the next round is
looking
it's loaded
stacked
first
we have
what has quickly become mine and many
people's favorite moments is jordan
peterson crying over the state of men
posted for by red-pilled knowledge
red pill knowledge ladies and gentlemen
[Music]
big ass [ __ ] like dry skin flake
uh what do we get here love
oh sorry i sent that in the wrong shot
okay
yeah
so
what the hell are we going to do
this is this is just my favorite i love
this so much what the hell are we going
to do without men what are we going to
do
here you see all these buildings go up
these men they're doing impossible
things they're under the streets women
could never build up buildings those
[ __ ] women are worthless
they're worthless
they don't work with their hands they
can't think straight
they're working in sewers
sewers they're up on the power lines in
the storms and the in the rain they're
keeping this impossible infrastructure
functioning
this thing that works in a miraculous
manner
they worked themselves
to death
you know
guys are we really this pathetic that we
need like
this [ __ ] sad song for ourselves just
get your [ __ ] together man it's not what
the [ __ ] do you want this is all just
because dudes can't get laid let's be
honest
this all just comes down to dudes can't
getting laid that's the only toxic
masculinity
oh there's a good comment let's leave
out the fact that many women who enter
these fields are subject to extreme
sexism and a hostile toxic work
environment
no what jordan peterson mr if you wear
lipstick you're asking to get sexually
harassed your eyes can get slapped on my
on your ass
no women wouldn't come in the sewer what
are they going to show up in high heels
and lipstick to work in the sewer
it's outrageous
men's women should be making sandwiches
raising children
men
should be getting drunk at the bars and
having sex with strangers
they work themselves to death they
deserve it
[Music]
and taking a benzo every once in a while
to take the edge off
to death
almost to death here listen let's keep
listening and often literally it's
very
useful to tell
everyone not just men that they have
an important role to play
a necessary role yeah i mean obviously
look the truth is that you know the
suicide rate is way higher for men and
uh life expectancy is lower so shout out
to the man obviously
you know it's true oh man my dog it is
true
not to discount the problems of men but
what am i gonna do without men
but anyway this is a great sound bite
but the hell are we gonna do without men
yeah so that's the sound by and we love
it so well
where would we be without men with
beautiful muscular bodies
i mean women are okay but i can't get
off to that
i would say being straight is probably
the manliest thing you could do is [ __ ]
another guy
think about it
i love muscles and hairy men and big old
raging [ __ ]
[Music]
i mean
what's what's manly about us a petite
little hairless woman
[ __ ] that give me a man
right
anyways that's that's jordan peterson up
against jeff widdick uh his
disastrous interview with us on
frenemies
yeah
here it is if there was a paywall on it
and you wanted to get those clicks
through doing it this way they had
lawyers
david's lawyers were threatening them
non-stop they have i don't know i i
don't know this stuff well i act like
i'm with david every day well it's in
the article if you would have [ __ ]
read the article
okay ethan
pretty bad pretty rough still one of my
favorite moments
of the entire show i mean again i do
i do like
acknowledge
that he came on the show which i
appreciate you know it's not easy no one
else did that
uh but he didn't read the article in
question and it didn't serve him well
i didn't realize someone just uploaded a
18 second clip and got 300 000 views
that's pretty cool
all right so uh
this is gonna be tough because i think
these are both beloved moments if there
was a paywall on it and you wanted to
get those clicks through doing it this
way they had lawyers
david's lawyers were threatening them
non-stop they have i don't know i i
don't know this stuff well you act like
i'm with david every day well it's in
the article if you would have [ __ ]
read the article
okay ethan
yeah i mean
you feel bad for him olivia i heard you
go all
why
i don't want to talk about it
nobody agrees with i don't i don't love
jeff i just is he your type
i mean
who's more your type him or island boy
definitely
jeff
definitely island boy i'm totally
kidding
however he did he did talk about
the only reason why i said oz because he
did talk about someone read it to him
but he was dealing with stuff with his
brain
never mind extract delete me from this
conversation my client has no more
further he's full of [ __ ] he didn't read
the article at all he had no he had no
interest in actually examining what was
going on and he viciously attacked
everybody that was reporting on it and
then came on our show and was like a
sarcastic [ __ ] about it
i was not zero [ __ ] sympathy for that
guy zero douche i let dan uh let dan uh
represent me on these matters
anyway i'm only representing myself like
i'm sure you feel
you're i mean you're nicer than me i i
feel i do feel bad for jeff and i mean
but okay whatever let's not relitigate
the whole damn thing we're just talking
about okay ethan first what are we going
to do without men so this is a tough one
love them both
[Music]
you know
this is going to be a closey maybe we
haven't really had any close ones yet
this might be our first let's see yeah
the ones that were 60 40 are probably
the closest we've had i couldn't guess
which one's gonna go yeah
i actually don't
oh wow definitely close
within five percent
wow wow wow wow wow oh
let's let it ride for a little bit so
the situation on oh my god
we have what are we gonna do without men
50
okay jeff 50
this
is astonishing
9 000 votes in still 50 50.
this is unprecedented on
can you see the exact vote or does it
just show percentage
uh
just okay
what are we going to do without man took
a slight lead there 51-49
guys get your voting because this is
important this is close your vote
matters
52 percent what are we going to do
without men
this is true
guys get your votes in this is important
your vote matters democracy in action
come on now
if 52 percent
what are we gonna do without men
oh another update
15 000 votes are have been cast
everybody
one more update let's get it in there
before we call it 52 what are we going
to do with that man
16 000 votes
well
seems to be holding steady with jordan
ryan cavanaugh if you're watching get
your bots in
17 000 votes i think we have a winner
here in our closest
battle yet yeah
what are we going to do without men
inches
it just ticked up again it's holding
steady at 52 so jordan what are we gonna
do without polls
people are voting
people are taking to the taking to the
streets to vote
men
[Music]
women they can't vote women shouldn't be
able to vote let's be honest
their brains are too emotional men men
i mean my wife can make a really good
sandwich
and we just like to you know let people
do what they're good at
but we're doing a possible things we're
voting in polls
we're doing podcasts
it's unbelievable
[Music]
come on
me
me men all right
wow all right congratulations dr jordan
peterson put a lot of respect on his
name
oh this is a really recent entry
um this is brand new britney spears
with their her little white claw gabe
impression
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] balls whoa girl [ __ ] wow
oh my god ah
holy [ __ ] wow [ __ ] balls eh
yeah holy [ __ ] balls
yo this is brittany unchained this is
[Laughter]
the conservatorship is over and brittany
is unchained my friends this is
this is everything so
is this is why we fought so hard to free
her
and up against brittany
is uh tim poole
also very
prolific sound bites used quite a bit
here he is saying that i
the fact
is
and that's why people like stephen
crowder should not debate him and that's
why steven was right for cutting him off
and saying no
and ethan klein is is
damaging everything making it all worse
because his interest his personal gain
first pop culture crap he doesn't know
what he's talking about so he would
rather watch people suffer if it gives
him a few extra bucks that's
that's tim's civil war civil war pool
ladies and gentlemen
klein what the [ __ ] did i do
yeah
yeah stephen crowder is it's serious
business
and then also he did the flaming turd
bag uh from the same vid yeah as well
here it is caring about the world and
being a self-interested
you know whatever when ethan steps in
and just throws a flaming bag of turret
you know flaming turd bag right in the
middle of the real [ __ ] you talking
about bro
flaming turd bag pretty good stuff i
mean
start flaming
turd bag
you know flaming turd bag
i guess he's talking about like when you
were a kid and you would ding dong ditch
and light a bag on fire i think that's
what he was going for yeah yeah
and i'm gonna get pissed off about it
you know i did that once as a kid
and you just what happens is you come
with the poop yeah oh because i didn't
gotten ditched but i don't think i ever
did the bag i think we tried it once and
what happens is um
you come back and all there is is a
burned bag and a piece of dog [ __ ]
because nobody actually steps on it
like that doesn't actually happen
yeah
disappointing
all right
i'm gonna pull it there it is brittany
holy [ __ ] balls versus tin pool flaming
turd bag of turkey i mean i feel like i
know which one's gonna win but you never
know
[Music]
you never know
you do you feel like you know
a little i'm questioning it my
prediction i'll wait but let's see
[Music]
yeah i would predict a britney
nobody cares about tim poole
i think his temple drop is better though
as good as it is
as useful as it is right nobody gives a
[ __ ] about tim pool
and those britney
that britney clip is
[ __ ] fantastic
so let's call it
britney spears takes the dub
sorry tim
i have ruined everything yet again
this guy is a manipulative lying con man
he said that about me
he did i think about sam cedar um i
don't remember
could have been you could have been sam
cedar
all right i'm ending it
brittany
what was that that was her
birthday dude that
that is a great video that brittany made
so
up next we've got this
yo
i feel like this one has potential man
the shack delete me from this
conversation is so good he went on like
this nelk podcast and they were all
talking about oh i [ __ ] like a hundred
girls and before nelk i couldn't get any
[ __ ] but now that i'm with milk and i'm
rich and famous i [ __ ] girls like crazy
and
shaq was like delete me from this
conversation they're just flexing on the
ground and they're just talking about
the ladies because i like my privileges
oh it's even worse than that they're
like girls on instagram are just they're
just trying to get they're just trying
to find a rich husband wake up is to
just like take photos so they can
eventually like bag like a rich guy well
yeah like they're literally just flexing
on the gram and they're just
talking about the ladies because i like
my privileges with the ladies
you guys just got [ __ ] told off by
shaq you all should have moved on real
quick when he when he said that probably
[ __ ] with tinder but yeah you can send
messages on instagram that's what i
don't mess with i tried to get on tinder
but they didn't believe it was me
really yeah i was like ryan you've been
a riot
isn't he married what's shaq doing on
tinder
or maybe he's single can you imagine
matching with shaq on [ __ ] tinder
um he's not married i don't think it
says he was married from 2002 to 2011.
but let me does him well okay so he's
there now he has a girlfriend is that
the little one or is that a new one
her name was shawnee o'neill
that's his last name
right that's the that's the wife that's
his ex-wife ex-wife oh the really short
girl was his ex-wife i believe so
man can you imagine matching with shaq
on tinder though like what do you do
with that
delete me from this conversation
now that the short girl was his uh
girlfriend okay okay yeah
he needs to date like someone who's like
at least six two
otherwise it will look like another
situation where
she's five six and he's seven one
he's seven one i didn't realize he was
that tall
holy [ __ ]
anyway shout out to shaq for creating an
absolutely
fantastic uh sound bite and being
actually just mature and speaking some
sense to these young
morons these pathetic womanizing freaks
i don't know why he was there in the
first place but at least he
uh
you know said something good to him
so
we've got shaq
first another really really really
iconic one here
coming from ex-president
donald trump
gentleman
and what he wants so badly 13 years old
ian lon fay
he's an 8th grader from arizona
and please stand up ian stanley has
always dreamed
ian stand up stand up ian
stand up stand up right now please stand
yes
ian please stand up he's up and stand up
please stand stay
up again okay
please stand down
stand up
now the chair again
it's kind of hard
it's not difficult stand up damn stand
up dan
ethan please stand up of course
zach please stand up
zach
[Applause]
just putting it in my face
oh cause there is no way you want to
avoid here we'll just stay seated it's
okay
yeah we'll stay seated for it maybe
well those that's pretty stiff i mean
you got shaq versus trump
two titans two tigers
let's see where the chips fall all right
i am
starting her up here we go
again i think
i for me i feel there's a clear winner
here
i'm gonna wait till the votes come in
because i don't want to
pollute the jury pool oh [ __ ] it looks
like we're pretty close whoa
hmm
i mean the stand were you gonna say the
shack one was yes no because the stand
up is like an iconic thing on the show
oh we're down to a four four point
spread the thing is delete me from this
conversation is so funny and so good
mm-hmm
oh
my god
oh wow my comment couldn't have made
that effect could it have no i think
it's just close enough that it's yeah
yeah i think it's just close enough wow
okay so now shaq is up by one point here
get your votes in people your vote
matters shaq is winning 51
trump 49
[Music]
13
000
votes cast
let's get those last minute votes in
guys
14 000 votes cast 51
shaq
49 percent trump so close this is the
closest by far
yeah i mean oh my goodness
the last one was a two point spread or
four point spread if you would yeah
and this one is just so close
15 16 000 votes and
it stays the same 51 shack 49 trump
let's take one more
one more dump we need the massive dumps
okay we just got our last dump
with sixteen thousand two hundred and
seventy three votes cast fifty one
percent shack
forty nine percent trump we oh and there
we go that's 52 shack that's a clear
winner
for shaquille o'neal
delete me from this conversation another
l for trump not a good year well trump
trump is out i mean you know he's not
even
shaq
listen mr president
i feel like we conducted that fairly i
don't know what to tell you the shock
one like is great for awkward
conversations yeah and like it will
always work
i adore that sound bite
it's so good and the usage of it
in the original
video
okay this is really interesting the next
um
[Music]
the next bracket
we have demi lovato
the i guess and the quartering are we
teaming up here this is a weird we kind
of we have all these edits that kind of
bounce between the two sound bites and
so
okay well demi lovato had an infamous
story this year
the yogurt store didn't have the yogurt
she wanted it ruined her whole week as
you know uh
they wanted
they wanted sorry thank you baby life is
hard as rank cavanaugh said can you
believe this world we live in
you know millions of people are starving
in afghanistan from famine
and and the collapse of their economy
but demi lovato can't get the yogurt she
wanted and uh well that ruined her week
so
three times a day this is something that
will live that will be with me for the
rest of my life
i left that yogurt
store and didn't get the yogurt that i
wanted and then i had a hard time the
rest of the weekend to be totally
transparent and that's probably
something that nobody wants me to say
like i'm
yeah so what's worse is she tagged
or sorry they tagged the yogurt store
and worse and they were sending
a bunch of [ __ ] they were uh review
bombing them on uh which is like and
stuff like that
like dude it was so it was so beyond
three times a day this is something that
will live that will be with me for the
rest of my life
i left that yogurt
store and didn't get the yogurt that i
wanted and then i had a hard time the
rest of the weekend i mean this was one
of the most insane things
from an out of touch celebrity that i
have ever seen i mean
this is way worse than bill gates saying
that pizza rolls cost 25 bucks whatever
you remember that [ __ ] when he was on
ellen
how much are these pizza rolls oh about
i don't know a hundred dollars i would
guess so
so that's demi
and then you have jeremy whose wife went
out for pizza without him and these are
being combined
my wife went out for pizza without me
and i'm angry about it
so i'm gonna win this round and i'm
gonna pee
if i don't win this round i'm gonna pee
in my own basement there you go wife
take that
she you know how much she hates when i
pee in the basement
and it sprays all over the wall it's
impossible to clean it's impossible to
get rid of the smell this man is sitting
in a basement with the smell of urine
wafting up into the main portion of the
house
that's awesome uh so what's the relation
here zach go ahead and play the sound
bites my wife went out for yogurt
without me and then i had a hard time
the rest of the weekend
i think you should just i think we
should nominate just the my wife went
out for pizza without me probably
really
or whatever i mean it's just weird to
include them both in one bracket i think
but well i feel like it's food decisions
i mean that's the one that we play the
most on the show is why we so play it
again zach
it's like food disappointment my wife
went out for yogurt stop me and then i
had a hard time the rest of the weekend
can you make it longer where he's like
and i'm gonna pee in my own basement and
then i [ __ ] all over the floor yeah i
feel like it's missing a beat
well anyway that mashup is against uh
phase blanks
frequent
sound by uh recipient
right phase
blinks
i think he's [ __ ] stupid to be honest
and it's funny because he refers to me
his face blanks says i'm dumb
um
h3 if you listen to this i'm infinitely
smarter than you
and infinitely more successful than you
[Music]
i just i i love this so much
he's infinitely smarter and infinitely
more successful
not only yeah we got him saying phase
blanks i mean come on it doesn't get
better folks it doesn't
so shout out to the phase blanks with
this 150 billion iq move of
saying phase blank so we could sound
bite it
um and then there's another one here
that we're going to group with it
we just cracked you already know we just
cracked the funniest humor the whole
time just like
i don't know because in the real world
like
i i can't even get through this [ __ ]
they you know he ain't cracking no funny
humor
face yeah oh he's a laugh riot face
blinks we be cracking the funniest humor
bro you know sometimes we run into these
like weird little h3h3 situations where
people just
are just really just talking [ __ ] you
know what i mean like back and forth
it's all talk it's just [ __ ]
you know twitter fingers um yeah but in
the real world bro people don't behave
like that they don't operate that way so
it's just it's funny to be in um like
real life situations like an event or a
party or so this is where keemstar
panics because he's afraid
faze blanks may actually be um
complimenting me
and keemstar is a little bit of a panic
and they start fighting on the show
incredible stuff something social like
that and just
it just hits you it kind of hits
everyone like [ __ ] is so dumb just crack
wait what the [ __ ] what is this story
are you high bro yeah what are you
talking about you started you started
talking about jason nash right he's
saying
me and jason ash crack like h3h3 humor
when we're with each other and like just
make like funny comments about the
internet and just he's a [ __ ] really
funny guy and his he's got a good soul
that was my point i would love to have
him on the show not i'm so confused h3h3
is not funny
dude keemstar is such a dumb like he can
even just let it go
he's like wait why are you complimenting
ethan we gotta go back and you're
[ __ ] high we all agree ethan's not
funny right nobody nobody here thinks
ethan's funny right
he was about to block faze banks on
twitter right then he was waiting for it
it's funny because keemstar has always
been i feel like
he's consistently always been like
ethan's funny but he's a piece of [ __ ]
or he was always like yeah i'll admit
that was funny
he's a fan yeah jose used to be funny
oh it used to be funny okay and he'll
say he's welcome for people to tease him
but the moment someone does he blocks
them or
i used to think you were funny before
you you started making fun of me
anyway here for this i'm not talking
about bro are you [ __ ] high right now
i'm talking about jason h no i'm talking
about jason nash being funny i'm saying
we crack jokes about h3
like in
that is
just not what he says how dumb all like
they do not like
they're actually so dumb they're
speaking right past each other and even
i don't know what anyone's talking about
i think that i think that faze blanks
was saying that he was
him and jason nash would react to in
urban videos together and crack each
other up basically and then realize that
he stepped in it saying that and
completely 180 because what he clarifies
he was saying is
nothing like what he had just said
it's just a total flip he's a fan dude
it's a great it's a great podcast really
it's awesome when the two hosts can't
even understand each other it's really
good
so you got phase blanks
uh demi lovato slash the quartering
let's see
dropping it
my wife went out for yogurt without me
and i [ __ ] my own basement [ __ ] all over
the floor that's what we need zach yeah
[Music]
those blank straps are too good i mean i
love the blank strap
play all the blank shops for a sec
[Music]
oh [ __ ] okay
blanks
blanks what the [ __ ] are you saying oh
it's a whoa it's a blanks out it's a
blanks out it's just i feed my yogurt
someone said i peed i just peed in my
yogurt
i cannot get mine and it ruined my whole
weekend i'll mash them up i just peed in
my yogurt and it ruined my whole weekend
i'm gonna carry this with the rest of my
life
well that's a big dub for phase blanks
congratulations sorry demi it does keep
narrowing every drop but i don't it's
still got a spread it's still got a big
spread sixty-two percent phase blank
blank
38 demi i'm so sorry demi and quartering
faze blanks is infinitely smarter and
more successful than both of you and
then i had a hard time the rest of the
weekend yeah i know his sound bites are
just too clean his voice is so deep that
they're perfect they are so perfect he
just sounds like such a dumbass one
blanks
i am infinitely smarter wow this next
bracket is exciting
these are two
big big contenders
you've got first the ace family
talking about how his it wasn't him who
scammed his fans it was his mysterious
partner
who scammed um and it kind of like hurt
us in a way because
in reality
like
you guys got scammed
um
like
the way the site was built it wasn't by
the way i love how he addresses his uh
his fans paying for something they've
never gotten getting scammed on
instagram live
yeah like let's bury this there's 15 000
people watching let's bury this word
nobody ever gonna see this [ __ ]
scam built to the degree that we needed
to be because obviously yeah it's not
your fault right
so mysterious developers so go ahead
zach play the clean sound bite please in
reality you guys got scammed
but she's been great for when we most
recently been talking about the ace
family though the news yeah it's been
great
yeah
okay he's family revival and that's a
good sound by that sound bite would win
against almost any sound bite
but
from the shadows
the wedding has passed
and the queen
is back upon her throne
see
all righty
you you
you you
so we've got phase blanks first
five percent no no no we have uh ace
family you guys got scamming oh [ __ ]
that's uh refreshers there sorry you in
reality you guys got scammed so play
them both
went off a bit of a tangent here
a little bit go ahead zach in reality
you guys got scammed first
the
five percent he takes that five percent
all right there we go it's the cali one
the cali one all right all right well
let's throw it to the vote i'm throwing
it up
um i wonder who will win
[Music]
yeah i wonder who's gonna win this one
i mean you got scammed is such a good
one you know you got scans is great it's
a shame
that it's probably gonna go wow
[Music]
89 he takes that 5
and that should tell you something
because
you guys got scammed is a s-tier sound
bite
and i feel like he takes that five
percent is
is a
competitor here s plus he takes that
five percent well i'm just going to end
it early because yeah
this ain't happening
that's a dub for sure
shout out to
uh cali or kaylee or whatever [ __ ] your
name is
five percent
he thinks that i love that she thought
she was doing something with that video
didn't she end up deleting it
and that's always their defense of like
i deleted it after i was up after
everyone was telling me how [ __ ] dumb
of a take it was but it was but
everybody already downloaded it you
already said it and you tried some [ __ ]
it ain't my [ __ ] fault you're an
influencer don't act like you're not she
is she's been on the videos she has her
own own f o f account she's she's she's
an internet personality i don't give a
[ __ ]
got five percent of an operating brain
[Applause]
of an operating brain
she does she does seem very dumb
yeah yeah yeah now she comes across as a
yeah
right dumb ass not very bright um
all right
sorry so the neck the next round is
looking very strong uh yo triller my
thing is flipped [ __ ]
iconic i mean iconic noah back who
apparently is a equity holder and
triller for christ's sake my floating
goes on triller my channel talks about
how their app sucks
go ahead noah take it away
yo trailer my thing's flipped
my camera's like flipped around right
now but look
i'm i'm trying to uh it's so awkward
what is it hey guys like look it's when
i put it this way oh i see it yeah weird
it's like mirrored aim should i head off
i love at the end he's like
oh this app sucks this [ __ ] is flipped
it's [ __ ] horrible ugh it's all
flipped
ugh this thing's a nightmare ryan
cavanaugh's a real [ __ ] idiot
so great one
and then don jr coming out with another
s tier
uh
hey guys hope you're doing well just
watching my own rhythms get crushed
i guess i did something to piss off the
instagram gods so
hopefully you're seeing this stuff
[ __ ] [ __ ] angle man
it's similar to white claw gabe how
white claw gabe sometimes lays in his
bed
[ __ ] baby crushing my algorithm
my algorithms [ __ ] [ __ ] baby you know um
don jr my algorithms are getting crushed
iconic
beautiful soundbite what can i say so we
got two two heavyweighters heavy lifters
here
and um noah beck
they're both great first don jr here
yeah yo triller my thing is flipped and
just watching my algorithms get crushed
let's take the vote it's flipped
watching my algos get crushed now we're
almost to the end of the first round and
from here it's going to it's going to
because we won't have to review each one
yeah okay uh
i'm clicking the button
and
let's see
what we get
all right
triller oh wow okay so triller my thing
is flipped
uh the first dump 79
triller massive dumps there's going to
be more massive dumps coming yeah so
let's wait and see 5 000 votes are in
that's a substantial amount
triller my thing is flipped at 78
percent
uh that's a w we can lock that up
a blowout
uh so awkward
you know
and people who are on a delay and so you
know you don't get to the point that you
see it it
it's at 78 it's it's not flipping oh
it's so flat oh yeah sorry if people are
waiting but yeah i mean in the interest
of the time i keep seeing people say
like by the time we say it's done it's
uh it has it it's yeah we have we have
we have statistically
more than enough to call it i mean 10
000 votes 79
that's yeah it's not flipping just like
trailer
that's not flipping
all right now back congrats
let's move you on
yeah we only have three more match-ups
and then we are out of the first round
the quarterfinals i believe you will
call that a
uh that's right
all right well up next the basically
what is in my opinion one of the most
iconic moments in internet history
um and was a snubbed last year and what
could only be described as a tragic
oversight
we forgot to include
peace and love
green goes star so
this year he's making an entry
uh here he is ringo starr
this is a serious message to everybody
watching my
update right now peace and love peace
and love
i want to tell you
please
after the 20th of october do not send
fan mail to any address
that you have nothing will be signed
after the 20th of october if it's got
the dates on the envelope it's going to
be tossed i'm warning you with peace and
love but i have too much to do so no
more
thank you thank you and no objects to be
signed nothing
uh anyway peace and love peace and love
classic
classic i have too much to do with peace
and love
love that man
so up against a new entry and a powerful
one william shatner went to space
complements of jeff bezos on his giant
penis
and
he had some great yeah
oh jesus oh jesus
[Laughter]
no
description
of this
wait
this is nuts
oh
god
this is uh
oh wow
i'm telling you
oh
holy hell
[Music]
wow
how did you get such clean sound bites
zack i uh boosted the game go ahead and
play the sound bites they're so clean
when you play them i can't believe this
oh jesus oh my god
oh my goodness me
oh i'm telling you
i'm telling you
oh
listen i know like blue origin which is
bezos's space tourism thing if they want
to make a commercial use those shatner
sound bites those are [ __ ] makes me
want to go to space
i'm telling you weightlessness
weightlessness
oh i'm telling you oh
lord
i mean they're great for when we're
talking anything sexual related all
right wow so those those are always uh
i'm going to launch the poll because
i've i
based off of what i'm seeing in the chat
i think this is going to be a really
close one so we're gonna okay we're
gonna need some time yeah i mean i think
if we ran peace and love last year it
would have been a really strong
competitor it's a little bit old now
uh but you know what still used all the
time though so it will be a blowout
surely you think so you think peace and
love blow up
oh yeah
i also think so right yeah okay well so
far peace and love first dumps in first
love at 67
uh not a i won't call that a blowout but
a strong strong commanding lead
tightening a little bit on round two
5000 votes in
66 peace and love 34
oh wow 7 000 500 votes are in it's
looking like a clean
lock for our beloved
beetle
ringo star this is a serious message
with peace and love thank you
peace and love
wow
on the next dump so ringo
congratulations
all right
calling it
oh my goodness oh my
sorry sorry william
so next up
really really good stuff here
jaw rule
friend of the show
the fire festival man i mean this
conference call
where ja rule is basically
scrambling to explain the giant
dangerous fraud that was fire festival
has one of the greatest lines
in business history
come on guys there's a lot of smart
people on this [ __ ] phone call man
let's think of how to dig ourselves out
of this [ __ ]
we didn't kill anybody nobody got hurt
we made a mistake we'll get past it
i mean grant nobody died but we did flat
out lie to the public about what we're
giving them
i mean that's fraud
like and that's not okay like as a
company operates
that's not fraud
that's not fraud
that is uh i would call that uh false
advertising
love
that [ __ ]
[ __ ] love that [ __ ] so technically
what we've dominated though is uh is
zach's edits of it which have breathe
new life into all these drops yes
i would call that a fraud
yeah by the way
by the way false advertising i'm pretty
sure is a type of fraud yeah i think so
i mean at least colloquially i would
call that uh false advertising i mean
the whole gambit of jaw rule sound bites
is has left its mark on this show
and
it cannot be it cannot be uh
you can't
you got to appreciate it absolutely
but we're up against
a combination of hell yes is okay
we've got jeff bezos with his psychotic
uh dr evil hell yes disturbing
grander space ambitions than going to
the edge of it did this moment motivate
you to push deeper into the cosmos hell
yes
god he's [ __ ] disturbing he's one
disturbing man
hell yes
so then there's the hell yes by bezos
and the hell yes by dream
when dream broke his world record
albeit while cheating
hell yeah hell yeah
all right so what's the match up zack
well it's just both of those he always
plays them back to back yeah and we're
when we're hell yesing when we're hyped
give us an example
hell yes
hell yeah hell yeah
all right and play the fraud for us one
more time
you could put it up then i would call
that a fraud
cracks me up man it cracks me up the
front
oh yeah i love it
love it love it
[Music]
you know i think i know the winner for
me there's a clear winner there it is i
would call that fraud 87
it's a blowout guy
that's not fraud no that one's not fraud
yeah
that one's legit i mean it's eighty-five
percent five thousand votes and we can
wrap it up
the drink yeah the dream hell yeah is
good don't get me wrong and so is the
basils but
come on
okay it's jaw let's go
and then this is our final bracket of
the first round
things are going to really pick up from
here
we've got woo friend of the show
and
you know
one of the most interesting sound bites
because it
has prophesized so much
i mean we've seen so many
coincidences that have come out through
this
and there's no such thing as a
coincidence here it is it's
william there is no such thing as a
coincidence the fact that you're
watching this video means you're
energetically aligned with me and this
message
your thoughts create your reality
but you already knew that yet you still
live a life that you dread
that is because when you visualize your
and he claims this is 100 real right
i believe so i don't know if i believe
it but i believe it i do believe it
i totally believe well you already knew
that yeah you still live a life that you
dread
when you visualize
oh man if this is real and i do think it
is he says it's real and i believe him i
think this is uh one of the best [ __ ]
things ever man yeah you still live a
life that you dread
that is because when you visualize your
dream life
yeah
that's a good one
there's no such thing as a coincidence
first our very own dan swerdlov
i'm gonna come and i can't trick off to
this
and you know the word the what jerk
offline really really comes in handy
that way wait zach you should be choking
from the front yeah i don't think anyone
chokes from the back it's the front i
can't jerk off to this
[ __ ] yeah i mean choking from the go
ahead and play the sound bite for a sec
i can't jerk off to this yeah and it's
really good i mean that one comes in
really good use
and of course there's the
i'm gonna come
i'll do whatever bts is doing i i i'm
gonna come
out of the closet right now and let
everything how did you think
i mean he said come real funny
it's just something when did you pull
that oh there was like a million
comments on that episode
with time's time
and i'm like
when we were taping it i didn't even
it went over my head i didn't even hear
it yeah of course that's what i would
expect yeah uh but it's you know god
bless dan for that one
sexual being over here
orgasm lord i'm gonna come
all right well that ends our first round
we are moving on we didn't vote
right right
so
i'm sorry i'm starting it right now yeah
they're both great i mean you know
obviously
stick your finger i think she can't [ __ ]
[Music]
stick your finger in me and i'm gonna
come
[Music]
i don't know i mean yeah oh
[ __ ] dude you're beating what no such
thing as a coincidence wow i call that
an upset i thought it was i call that an
upset but how do you feel about that dan
you feel honored
to be above william knight that no such
thing as a coincidence guy that is i'm
going to come that is quite annoying
that's quite an honor that's a huge dub
that's 65 percent
i can't jerk off to this 35 percent no
such thing as a quad incidence we got 9
000 votes in
11 000 votes in man oh man that's a
funger
one
[Applause]
the big leagues now we're moving on to
the corner finals do you mind i i gotta
pee really bad i have to
really so let's just throw it to a quick
slate here five minute break with some
fun h3 music okay we'll take a five
minute break
when we come back we're going to do the
quarterfinals the semifinals and the
grand championship stay tuned it's going
to go fast now we're just going to vote
boom vote boom this is going to be huge
so we'll throw it to a quick break we're
going to play some fun music stay tuned
we'll be right back
[Music]
me
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if
[Laughter]
da
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
me
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right we're back are we back we're
back thank you guys for waiting
so apologies to uh
you know i kind of went off on tricia so
i want to apologize to the uh vegan with
uh rabbit cart kisses on her uh dining
room table
and steak for her wedding meal yeah
actually no i saw the menu it was all
vegetarian
she posted a mukbang oh they were eating
steak yeah
apologies i know she's a vegan now she's
transcended
oh boy
i was bottled up what can i do you know
[Music]
all right let's let's wrap let's do this
eh yeah
all right so
so back to the top
all right we are in the semi-finals now
this is where
it's real we get
we cut to the chase
this is where it all happens
our first
[Music]
okay so we have wendy williams just
saying
first trump i've been listening to
olivia the whole time play him play him
you can get the pull-up dan play him
zach to
refresh the memories die
just saying
versus death to all of them
i've been listening to olivia the entire
time
all right so we've got wendy williams
just saying
slash die plus whatever the [ __ ]
and trump i've been listening to olivia
the whole time this is our first
semi-final showdown
[Music]
uh
it's gonna be it's gonna be tough i
don't know i feel like i fee i'm feeling
a blowout here yep that's what i thought
wendy williams such a great collection
of sound bites well hold on there's only
one thousand votes
you gotta give it a little more time oh
that that actually just
increased the spread
[Music]
yeah sorry trump you're not overcoming
that kind of uh margin 73 wendy williams
27 trump
6 000 votes in i think we can call that
a w
sorry sorry olivia for wendy
you
all right so that's our first victor in
the semi-finals
huge dub
wendy
next up we've got keemstar shut up [ __ ]
verse a b or love
a did that everyone saw it go ahead and
team star shut up
shut up [ __ ]
shut up
you know and and really put keemstar in
this place which is i think we need to
cherish that moment uh for it really is
beautiful
uh versus uh
evie did that everyone saw that
also powerful beautiful moment
thank you thank you it's a big showdown
i foresee a big another blowout
unfortunately you do i do i'm scared
um i do
all right well i am initiating the vote
um
oh oh okay not a blowout it's all [ __ ]
so this is like melody festival we have
1600 votes and 52 keemstar shut up
wow 5 000 votes in 52 keemstar shut up
48 ab did that everyone saw it's a tight
one guys get your votes in we want to
make sure we get
uh accurate yeah we're gonna okay yeah
inching up on keemstar 8 000 votes and
53 keemstar looks like we have
yeah 10 000 votes and fifty four percent
keemstar that's a dub for game ten
seconds left
um
i think that's a l sorry sorry love
ten thousand votes in that's fifty three
percent keemstar
shut up [ __ ] which we love so well
and uh you know love you you put on a
good battle semi-finals definitely good
showing oh oh yeah i'm very happy to
make you thank you
and you're up against a really good
sound bite there so oh yeah absolutely
yeah
nothing to be ashamed of
absolutely no all right all right i'm
calling it ending the poll
okay so we have our first uh
first bracket for the we have our first
quarter final bracket there right which
is going to be wendy versus keemstar
that one's going to be real interesting
okay next below we've got the rock shut
up [ __ ] versus dubrick go ahead
[ __ ]
that is [ __ ] strong
that is a strong contender
dubrick versus my mom saying david
dubrick
again sensing a blowout but let's see
what the people think
all right
initiating
[Music]
the pole
sensing a blowout here
[Music]
shut up [ __ ] dogs are strong
i don't know for oh yeah that's kind of
again
not that strong i mean initial let's
wait we get some more votes in here for
another big dump but initial is showing
82 percent shuttle [ __ ]
six thousand votes seventy nine percent
shut up [ __ ]
twenty percent dubrick that's looking
like a big w
for
the rock
[Music]
yeah that's 9 000 votes 77 shut up [ __ ]
we're blasting through these
um
congratulations to the rock sorry
to all the darn arcs out there the
competition is just too stiff this year
up next we've got keemstar in a book huh
and it was used in a book huh
versus
what are we gonna toxic masculinity
how are we gonna do without men what are
we gonna do without men
versus in a book now this one's a
coin toss for me you know
yeah both
really strong two
extremely strong
competitors here
um keemstar and a book huh
versus what are we gonna do without men
all right paul
is initializing
two powerful power okay so we've got the
initial uh feedback here it's closer
than the other ones
with 2000 votes and 59 wow keemstar is
winning okay this is oh we just
tightened it by quite a bit seven
thousand votes and fifty three percent
in a book huh this is really close guys
get your votes in
this could go either way
nine thousand votes in
in a book huh
53
47 percent what are we going to do
without men this this is a close this is
our closest we've been five percent
okay it's still tightening 10 000 votes
52 in a book get your votes in guys this
is close close close
if it keeps tightening i mean we gotta
gotta wait this one out
yeah we're gonna wait this one out
eleven thousand votes fifty two percent
in a book huh
[Music]
my voice is starting to go
oh twelve okay so just tight it just uh
the the gap just widened yeah we got 12
000 votes 53 in a book i think we can
call that for keemstar and a book
huh sorry to the great doctor
jordan peterson what will we do without
men i just don't know where would we be
without men as if it was an option
as if it were an option to go forward
without men
all right
congratulations uh keemstar on that one
and where would we be without books huh
[Laughter]
so
absolutely that our net there you go you
got that that other semi-final bracket
is a shut up [ __ ] first in a book huh
so that will be interesting and going
down to our other semi-finals we got
holy [ __ ] britney spears for shaq
delete me from this conversation holy
[ __ ] wow [ __ ] balls eh
yeah holy [ __ ] balls
really good
delete me from this convo delete me from
this conversation okay yeah so again
powerful entries
i know which one i like i'm not going to
say it
both powerful in their own right
uh but
i know which one i would vote for
that's the one shecky
looking good 1400 votes 67 delete me
from this convo
let a little more votes get in here
5 000 votes 65 to leave me from this
conversation sorry brittany
um
we love you and we're glad we're you're
free but shaq
just a little too powerful delete me
from this conversation now with that
eliminated in this round it would seem
like unfortunately she's gonna have to
go back to the conservatorship oh stop
and dan that's her punishment no no no
we don't we stand a free britney
eleven thousand votes has shaq winning
shaq is in everything including this
uh sound by tournament just dunked on
delete me from this conversation well we
will not be deleting you from this
tournament just yet that's right shaq
takes the w
delete me
from this conversation
fantastic shaq's moving on next up phase
blanks versus cali he take that five
percent face blanks
you know
love the phase blanks
but is cali too powerful
he take that five percent
the five percent is even it's even
bigger than the show i mean i see that
everywhere now and five percent
yeah
trump you've got the rogan five percent
difference is astronomical and i see
five percent everywhere now
i see it all over the place and it
really is makes a lot percent yeah
yeah callie send me all your bills i'll
cover even though the show's over
i'm still sending trisha royalty so
that five percent is still in action
wow
yeah you know
unfortunately phase blanks the
competition is just
so strong and this is a blowout like you
wouldn't really expect to see in the
semifinals you got 89 percent you take
that five percent and it's not like i
mean the phase whites are strong too so
that's nine thousand votes in 89 he take
that five percent and yeah you're up
against a really strong face blanks
those are powerful sound bites people
yeah strong strong sound bites but
getting absolutely annihilated but he
take that five percent with 10
000 votes in 89
that is a clear clear
w
for cali congratulations to her he takes
that five percent five percent is indeed
everything
it's astronomical
all right so next now that's another
bracket delete me from this combo versus
he take that five percent coming up next
uh next round but until then
in the semifinals you've got yo triller
my thing is flip noah beck versus ringo
starr peace and love go ahead zach yo
triller my thing's flipped
uh it's all flipped
hit us with uh it's so awesome love
peace and love
and hit me with the uh it's so awkward
ugh it's so awkward
very good
and kept me with i'm warning you with
peace and love i have too much to do
i'm warning you with peace and love
thank you thank you
i think they're both great you know ooh
okay
now coming down to the wire here in our
semi-final showdown with 2 500 votes in
52 triller is flipped ringo starr
who was snubbed last year making an
appearance and doing quite well but he
may have met his match here yo triller
my thing is flipped at 52 with 9 000
votes 9 000 votes and people 52 yo
triller my thing is flipped it's tight
it's close it's a difficult match up
both powerful strong competitors peace
and love peace and love this is a
serious mess
after
the
after december 15th with peace and love
ringo starr will be
uh removed from this tournament he has
lost
our beloved beatle has lost to dude it
just narrowed to oh [ __ ] wait what what
12 000 votes fifty one percent yo
triller my thing is flip piece of love
forty nine percent it is tightening this
we could flip
we need all votes and thirteen thousand
guys thank you we need all the votes in
this is the tightest race so far in this
semi-final bracket 13 000 votes and 51
yo triller my thing is flipped this
could go either way get those votes in
these dumps we need those doms
it's holding tight at 51 we've got 13
000 votes in we need more votes this is
way too close to call guys come on
come on guys the the voting is right
there in the uh
chat 14 000 votes
51 yo triller my thing is flipped
so absolutely oh my god holy [ __ ] you
guys we have a statistical tie
fourteen thousand four hundred and
sixteen votes are and
ringo is happy to be making gains here
yo triller my thing is flip 50 peace and
love 50
this is a tiebreaker situation
15 000 votes guys get it in because this
this
this thing is tight wow this is a 50 50
vote
holy
mother of god
wow two
absolutely savage competitors at the top
of their game i can't believe can we
break this down and this can we see the
exact number i'm gonna look in the
back end of uh the studio right now to
see if it actually shows
more specifics because at this moment
guys
as more votes come in we're at 16. oh it
highlights which one it so
it actually just flipped peace and love
is even though it says 50 50 it's
highlighting peace and love because that
is the current leader no
way so
you're sure about that yeah it had been
on the top one this whole time and then
holy crap i'm still looking in the back
end to see if i can the votes are still
coming in we're at 16 600 votes it's 50
50. it looks like peace and love
actually took the flip
flip the flip the vote flip the script
peace and love
50 50.
16 750 votes you guys this is the
tightest competition wow yet
wow noah beck i am so sorry
he had that early lead but
uh the beatles fans came out in droves
to support ringo
this is a serious message
it's still 50 50.
this is insane this is insane it is
still 50 50 with 17 000 votes my my
people this is this is on
an unbelievable matchup
truly unprecedented here at the h3
podcast we've never seen anything like
this but i think at this point
it's it's still giving it to peace and
love at this point peace and love is
highlighted
17 500 votes are in
holy
stomally
i think that's it i think we got to call
it i think we got a call that is just so
close wow my condolences to noah beck
for because it's such an iconic drone
thank you thank you my thing is flipped
but wow you know ringo starr
iconic member of the beatles he still
got it after all these years still
producing bangers with 18
000 votes cast
peace and love is gonna take it all
right i'm calling wow i wish we could
see just how close it was yeah i'm
trying to we can tell we can tell based
on the way it's highlighting peace and
love that it's winning yeah people are
demanding a recount
i mean is it really going to change
anything maybe we should do a recount
with it being that close like it's a
freaking it's a total 50 50. like this
is a hanging chads situation for sure
i mean trump is calling the uh
the uh state the secretary yeah uh the
governor is making his pr agent to go
threaten people's families yeah this is
he is asking can we just find 50 more
votes nobody likes me
wow people are demanding a recount let's
do a quick recount it's way too close to
call it 50 50. okay all right
i'm at 18 500. oh this is okay the
recount guys recount this is too close
to call yo triller my thing is flipped
and the first recount of the 2021
h3 podcast championship we are having
our first official recount we ended up
after 20 000
votes
with a 50 50 stalemate way too close
white technical issue here give me one
more yo trailer my thing's flipped keep
playing them zach ugh it's so awkward um
uh it's all flipped
all right setting it up again okay
recount warning you with peace and
here we go and these are two absolutely
vital competitors as we close out the
year here we we honor both of them
uh true competitors
they've made such an impact on the show
it's hard to understate
we're back with the recount guys get
your votes in if you want your person to
win
now is the time close again peace and
love go with the early leaders it's
taken an earthquake
but it's lightning again
it's tightening so we have 8 000 votes
guys get your votes in this is where it
counts 8 000 votes in
52 peace and love at this moment
let's get those dumps in
yo trailer my thing's flipped get your
votes in before mike pillow comes in and
demands a recount
12 000 votes and 52 peace and love big
massive dumps oh no we need more dumps
here guys
they call them dumps
52
peace and love at 13 000 votes
this is just a nail biter 14 000 52
piece of love i think we got a winner
here because peace and love was was
ancient
was the one that ahead
catching up the whole time so with peace
and love
i think i have to say triller
know it back you are flipped
congratulations to ringo starr
wow had still got it after all these
years i was riveting
peace and love
the dark aura
how dare you that's why you wanted no i
refused that
ringo starr is peace and love he has no
dark auras shame on you
all right
next up we've got ja rule i will call
that uh false advertising versus dan i
can't jerk off to this
i would call that a fraud
let's think of how to dig ourselves out
of this makes me laugh every time do the
false advertising one
i would call that uh false advertising
[Music]
love ja rule
love the fire festival
uh fire festival debacle
so much fun so i'm gonna come
uh can you jerk off to this i can't jerk
off to this no cannot but you can come
to this stick your finger stick your
finger
well it's a toughy damn i'm gonna come
our very own dan
versus jaw rule
i'd be shocked if i can overcome jaw
well i don't know we'll we'll let's
let's see what the people have to say
okay
the votes are coming in
ja rule versus our very own dan
52 percent i call that fraud it's closed
down to another closing 3000 votes in
interesting
this is closer than i thought it'd be
[Music]
we need an oh
six thousand five hundred fifteen votes
we got fifty two percent i call that
fraud forty eight percent i can't jerk
off to this is a close close one guys
get your get your fungus in there
oh my goodness gracious another tight
battle oh my god 9 000 votes stick your
finger
11 000 votes i call that fraud still
holding strong at 52
i can't jerk off to this
down at 48
it is a tight tight margin another drop
but the lead is holding strong for jaw
rule it's not i can't believe it's this
close but it is it is holding steady
oh my god it just tightened uh-oh here
we go again guys you know the semi the
the some the quarter or we're in the
semifinal the semifinals
i mean this is the best of the best this
is the cream of the crop guys and this
is showing it here 14 000 votes 51 i
call that fraud the race is tightening
15 000 votes now 51 fraud holding strong
49 i can't jerk off to this let's think
of how to dig ourselves
[Laughter]
wow dan how do you feel you're putting
up a fight against the jaw rule he's a
legend i mean he's a legend um
um
i can't think of any of his songs right
now
you know
i expected the fraud one to kind of take
it away
but dan is showing a
powerful showing here 16 000 votes cast
51 i call that fraud 49 i can't jerk off
to this a tight tight battle here in the
uh semifinals 16 000 votes cast oh
it's back i think that's a we're going
to call it now because
oh it's a gap just wide open i call that
fraud is going to take the w at 52
percent
um dan
well done dan you should feel proud i
feel proud i i was a contender i went i
went the full uh rounds just like rocky
you should feel very proud of that dan's
a good man
thank you joe dan's a good man but
ultimately i mean listen jaw rule
it's a great [ __ ] sound bite it
really really is and so
and so that concludes our semi-finals
it's not actually the semi-finals
this is the quarterfinals no no it's not
even the quarterfinals it's just round
two it's the quartering the next round
is the uh quarterfinals and then the
semifinals and then the final oh the
semifinals is the okay
right so uh jaw moving on
to the quarterfinals
okay guys we have four brackets now this
semi
i'm going to call this the quarterfinals
that would be accurate because thank you
we're here in the quarterfinals with
four brackets this is really getting
down to the wire and this is when it
becomes it's gonna be tough a nail biter
guys up in our first bracket we have
wendy williams just saying
versus keemstar shut up [ __ ]
wow
death to all of them
die
wow i know what i want to win keemstar
shut up
shut up [ __ ]
it's just it's a tough one and we love
wendy williams it's such useful
material
but shut up keemstar [ __ ] put him in
his place and we love that
here we are the first round of the
quarterfinals
uh on the board get in your votes we
have wendy williams with a quick lead a
56 percent not a blowout there's still
time
fourteen hundred okay we have five
thousand votes now this is a substantial
voting uh
pool yep 58 wendy williams taking a
a quick lead there not a blowout by any
means but uh it's a it's a clear winner
now okay again 8 000 votes the gap has
widened wendy williams our beloved is
going to take the w here today
with 10 000 votes we're ending at 58
wendy williams death
toll
i mean yeah how do you compete wendy is
just she is uh toward the force
she is a tour de force
we love her
alrighty
the next round of our semi-finals
the rock
shut up [ __ ] shut up [ __ ]
versus in a book versus keemstar in a
book huh huh
and it was used in a book huh
yeah
two
fantastic sound bites the rock shut up
[ __ ] is honestly just iconic
uh but keemstar and a book huh
really good really interesting too
keemstar who has never read a book is
confused by the concept of in a book and
again another tight race here in our
semi-finals
300 votes 55 shut up [ __ ] this is a
tight one this is not a blowout by any
means guys get your votes in 5 000 votes
in 56 shut up [ __ ] 44 in a book huh
tight tight race we got a we got a
leader
okay in the rock shut up [ __ ] 55
percent 9 000 votes in
votes are rolling in
this is a close one it is close but
we've got a leader here and shut up
[ __ ] at 55 10 000 votes in his he holds
his lead at 55
wow here in round 26 of the semi-finals
of the 2021 history podcast champ sound
by championship 12 000 votes it's a
10-point spread i'm gonna call that shut
up [ __ ] by the rock now i gotta say
i thought the shut up [ __ ] was gonna
take up take a stronger lead i gotta say
i'm impressed by the keemstar showing
there today a strong competitor
absolutely putting up
numbers putting up a really good fight
there and as we come to the lower
bracket of our semi-finals these are our
last two brackets of the semifinals
delete me from this conversation shaq
delete me from this conversation
oh yes and a very good sound bite that
is butt versus the powerful kayley
cali whatever the whatever takes that
five percent he takes that five percent
this is gonna be a toughy man
this is a really really tough bracket
um some of our strongest competitors
happen to be in this bracket this could
easily be the finals in an alternate
universe yeah true
um
heath b oh my goodness we have the first
blowout of the semifinals he take that
five percent 70
margin this is a clear blowout there's
lots of cali fans in the audience
clearly it's showing
shaq we love you what a fantastic
submission to the issue sound by verse
but with eight thousand votes casted
seventy percent in favor he take that
five percent the first blowout and a
contender to win the whole damn thing
means everything could be cali
advances and congratulations to her
uh of course she took the tick tock down
after a short time but still it lives in
infamy doesn't it folks it does
you can't take
a week before i started working here i
went to a party and i told someone asked
me what i was doing this summer and i
was like i'm working um at this podcast
called age three and the first thing
they said to me was and he takes that
five percent
yes it's the five percent uh heard
around the world it's an important sound
bite yep historical
truly
well
at the very bottom of our quarterfinals
we have the last bracket ringo starr
peace and love
snubbed last year making a strong
appearance this year peace and love
peace and love verse jaw rule i would
call that a
fraud go
ahead i would call that a fraud i would
call that uh false advertising hit me
with some more ringo stars
thank you thank you
peace and love no more fan mail do the
do the i'm warning you with peace and
love all right let's see the voting it's
all right
wow
the love actually started first and then
on the second dumb switch so it's neck
and neck right now here in the
quarterfinals the competition is stiff
and we are having a lot of close battles
because today here we have 7
200 votes cast now 9500 votes cast i
will call that fraud is
inching out at 53 percent peace and love
snubbed last year making a strong
appearance but could this be the end of
the beloved ringo start 47 percent
uh 11 000 votes cast guys get your votes
in this is a close one
i call that fraud 12 530 votes 53
percent ja rules aro coming in close the
fire festival i'm warning you with peace
oh ringo is not happy with these results
i'm happy
he's not happy he's been and seen so
many things and come this far to lose to
john rule wow that's got to hurt
14 000 votes in
i would call that a fraud 53 percent ja
rule is gonna take the w here my friends
and you know with peace and love
to the one and only ringo starr
he has been dethroned by ja rule wow of
the fire festival i would call that a
fraud and now my friends we are here at
the semi finals the moment we've all
been waiting for we have just two
brackets left this is intense
here we go at the top
okay
wow
look at this wendy williams just saying
versus the rock
shut up [ __ ] now if you remember
just saying i believe both of these were
somewhat narrow winners in their
previous bracket
so it's gonna be tough to choose a
favorite here we're gonna have to leave
it up to the audience
but wendy williams
they both had to come through keemstar i
see that that's very interesting you
know and it was close
okay so the rock you know
a lot of lore a lot of a lot of uh
a lot of history here on the show versus
wendy williams also a favorite
wendy williams so versatile die go ahead
and play the soundbite zack give
everyone a death to all of them
oh very close
okay guys
the first semi-finals is underway i am
flabbergasted here today it's close
wendy williams is inched ahead at 53
6 000 votes cast i gotta say
i was i thought vin i thought the rock
was going to take it the shut up [ __ ]
was just that good but wendy williams
she's just she just has it all she's got
she's got that action
and i'll tell you what the gap is
widening wendy is is is is taking down
the rock wwf style it just went up again
wendy williams has double suplex the
rock and she has gotten him in a
chokehold he is about to submit
with 13 000
finishing wendy with 13 000 votes cass
wendy williams has got him in a choke
hold
and the rock is tapping out that is a w
for wendy williams 55 after 14 000 votes
congratulations i gotta say i thought
the rock would take that one i really
did
play that again
[Applause]
she's so overwhelmed with the motion
that she won
i just cannot discount you cannot
you can't discount wendy i can never
count her out wow what a strong
competitor i have to say so we have
that's our first finalist
so wendy williams enters into the final
bracket incredible just saying
i gotta say the rock made it far but wow
wow wow wendy williams is our first
finalist i thought for sure the shadow
pitch one i thought so too i did not
but
wendy has served this show never know
what's going to happen
wendy has frankly served this show
better than her own
it's true yeah
she's the shadow star of the show she's
my co-host yeah yeah
you owe her five percent absolutely if
anyone i i owe anyone it's windy five
percent
all right guys
all right our
lower bracket semifinals this is going
to determine
our final final showdown
guys we have he takes that five percent
by cali
he takes that five percent
has basically blown out every competitor
so far she has completely
dominated this bracket um and now she's
up against possibly her
strongest rival
ja rule i will call that a fraud
mm-hmm
here we go keep playing them all yeah
get give gerardo's dues i would call
that a fraud
like keep going
no way
no way holy smokes guys here at round 30
the last bracket of the semifinals right
on the eve of our final showdown
he takes that five percent with six
thousand two hundred votes
seventy four percent not even quite a
massive blowout for jaw rule
false advertising
and you know job role hasn't seen a
blowout like this since the lawsuits
over the fire festival this is bad bad
bad news for ja rule 11 000 votes and 72
percent he take that five percent callie
is sweeping it this year she has blown
out
every competition and if it reminds me
of anyone it reminds me of a young
upstart by the name of david guta who
took it last year dominating every
bracket swept the whole damn thing all
the way into the finals right and now we
have what seems to be
the new take away kid cali he take that
five percent that is a absolute blowout
here
in the semifinals
wow he takes that five percent
wow okay here we are here we are at the
finals should we should we perhaps
review the paths to this final that each
of these two had to take absolutely they
had to slay go ahead yeah
so
let's see wendy where did she start i
think you got to zoom out yeah
well if you put it on the front one it
will track the path i think it literally
won't let me scroll up there we go all
right so wendy actually started by
defeating last year's champion that was
her round one [ __ ]
and then took out trump
took out keemstar shut up [ __ ]
uh took out the rocks shut up [ __ ] all
these people were telling her to shut up
and she would not she's a strong
independent woman she will not be shut
down by any man
but i gotta resp i have to reflect a
little bit on wendy's path
uh to beat the rock shut up [ __ ] to
beat last year's world champ david giuda
shout out to the families uh wendy is
clearly
so powerful here it is and it really is
and to review uh
kaylee's path yeah so started with uh
austin mcbroom in reality you got
skating again that that could have
easily been a deep competitor deep
competitor uh face blanks in the scene
competitor huge shaq delete me from this
conversation these are all great anja
rules everything
i gotta say they had easy paths to
victory like they didn't this was not a
sweep by any means these are well
deserving finalists wendy williams
versus cali
and i got to say man
may the best woman win in this case i'm
blown away i would have never guessed
this wow
okay i'm setting up the pool now well
what would you have guessed zach i would
have guessed shut up [ __ ]
between the vin diesel family
that would have been my final really the
vin diesel those guys got shut out early
yeah seriously i'm shook to the curb
these were my top two i'm feeling good
about it really
okay i want to join your fantasy team or
whatever you are more than welcome
you know this is a tough one because
cali has been totally blowing everyone
out but the wendy williams one is just
really powerful it really is he takes
that five kids now before you put up the
poll
zach give us the full gambit
of all the sound bites we're judging
from today
die
die
just saying
you've been
death to all of them
wow is all i can say to that that's
strong so
powerful
wow
oh wow
versus one simple little passage it
takes up five percent
one simple little tick top but such
meaning
versus wendy's whole body of work
this is coming down dan this is tense
i'm nervous man i'm [ __ ] nervous man
but the intense music is rising my dad
put the pole up
here we go
wow
here we go guys final round
the votes are coming in
[Music]
oh my god okay oh
we're close we're close we're close
two thousand
okay this is wow
wow dude
six thousand six oh
no six thousand six hundred votes fifty
percent wendy williams fifty percent
take that five percent i cannot believe
what i'm seeing yes at this moment he
take that five percent has a narrow lead
we only know that because it's
highlighted but the poll itself is
showing 50 50 9 000 votes in we're at a
50 50. whitney webb just takes the lead
again
williams is highlighted
it's still at 50 50. 12 000 votes are in
it is a dead tie i cannot believe what
i'm seeing i'll take that fight
what is happening i've never seen this
level of competition before
13 000 votes 14 000 votes in 50
take that five percent it is 50 50
take that five percent it's got to
highlight i mean it's a narrow lead but
we're up to five fifteen thousand votes
oh my god fifty fifty 50
i cannot believe what i'm saying here hi
guys i cannot believe what we're
witnessing here on the h3 podcast with
16 000 votes in 50
when he was 50 take that five percent i
this is unbelievable the competition
we've never seen like this before
take that five percent it's still
highlighted but it's been flipping back
and forth this whole time i am just
beside myself folks this is the greatest
competition
17
000 votes take that five percent has
gained the lead 51 take that five
percent
it's all unfolding it is all unfolding
here
at the 20 21.
i'm speechless folks 2021 sound bite
championship we have a leader we have 51
percent he take that five percent we're
up to 18 000 votes guys let's get 20 000
let's get 20 000 in get your votes in
now your vote matters people 18.
oh
my [ __ ] just crashed but that's okay i
don't need it
18
000 votes
oh she's upset she's upset
that wasn't her
guys get your votes in eighteen thousand
five hundred votes fifty one percent he
take that five percent is there not more
wendy williams stands out there in the
audience to give it that little edge
wendy is angry she wants to kill people
guys we are inching it on 19.
19 000 votes
come on get your votes in we need 20 000
at least to call this because it is just
way too close too close 19 000 votes
this is perhaps our biggest showing
uh in terms of votership yeah yeah and
it and and well and while it should i
mean this is the
finals
wendy
51 we're almost to 20 000 votes we're at
19 255 votes guys get it in now 5 means
everything i cannot believe what we're
seeing here today this is unbelievable
i cannot believe
what we are seeing here today the hp
podcast sound by championship 2021
we're 500 away we're 500 away from the
end
[Music]
i'm just blown away here this is the
greatest competition man has ever seen
of all the sporting events of all of the
mash-ups of all of the fiercest
competitors in the history of mankind
this is perhaps the greatest showdown
we've ever seen nineteen thousand eight
hundred and eighty nine votes fifty one
percent he take that five percent guys
with about 111 votes left to seal the
deal he take and that is it it's over 20
000. it's over 36 votes 51
to take that five percent
wins by two percent and that my friends
oh
that was the right choice in my opinion
i agree
[Music]
wow
congratulations to cali
congratulations to the whole patis
family
they got a huge w in the family now you
know many say that callie has always
been the uh
always the bridesmaid living in the
shadow of her sister but today callie is
the champion with that five percent she
is the winner of the
most prestigious championship last year
it was won by the powerful david gutier
shout out to the family this year callie
takes it with he takes out not five
percent but two percent
i am blown away wow there's a
competition now i don't remember i don't
remember last year the finals being that
close i think david crushed
we'd have to go back and review but um
but david
yeah that was exciting an easier path to
victory
you know there was flip-flopping there i
was i was losing it i was like i i was
just absolutely blown away there intense
[ __ ] intense
[ __ ] hell well well let's get some
five percents going zach
he takes that five percent
five percent means everything five
percent difference is astronomical wow
we're gonna need more than five percent
family
family
family family family family family
family family family family family
family family
[Music]
what an honor for her
yeah wow
i could really congratulations to all
the contestants i mean just to be
included was an honor so shout out
but wendy was so close she was so close
she almost went the distance wendy was
getting pissed at the end there but you
know the thing is that the five percent
has so much going for it the fact that
wendy almost took the w
was just astounding yeah
so congratulations
what a riveting show my goodness
wow wow huh guys
wow we should let people know what's
going on tomorrow because it's very out
of the ordinary right so tomorrow
wait i'm yeah tomorrow because usually
we don't normally do a show on thursday
right okay so as you guys know co-host
of leftovers hassan [ __ ] was banned
from twitch for saying the word cracker
and i am d which is pretty weird as a
cracker
i am deeply deeply offended by that well
i was hoping he'd get arrested or
something from being so offensive well
that's why we're bringing him here so we
can beat the [ __ ] out of him yeah so
actually since he's banned we're going
to do our leftovers episode live
tomorrow and we have a lot of fun games
uh
i'm looking for example at a
do you want to give it a 30 gallon
tub full of crackers
so just to give you a little which is
not even close to all of them yeah just
to give you a little preview of what
we're planning
amaranth will be here as well we're
going to be um
taking a hot tub in a pool full of
crackers with amaranth and hassan we're
gonna be playing all kinds of cracker
related games that's right so we're
gonna be going live tomorrow at 12 30.
in fact one we can make the event when
we end this sure
it's gonna be great
so thursday live people are upset i said
that with a hard r
cracker
no i said cracker no but are we supposed
to say kraka that sounds worse that
sounds way worse that sounds worse
well because it just sounds like you're
you're mocking uh you
anybody can say it
well i'll be the judge of that okay
it's my word to say
it's my word too five percent that's my
word well what are you the spokesman for
all white people
no no i'm not
yeah i don't want i don't want that on
me
yeah there's a lot of them out there
there's a lot of white people i don't
want to know i don't want to donate yeah
delete me from this conversation all
right jack well it doesn't involve you
because uh this is our word shaq
so you are deleted from it
but anyway we're going to discuss all
that so we're going to be live tomorrow
12 30
leftovers and then friday we're going to
be live again so many lives and then
next week's our final week that's right
and it's only a half week because
there'll just be a monday and a
wednesday show
it's the end of the year so we're going
all out here guys we're pulling all the
stops with the championship and next
week we've got a really special final
episode of the year we'll taking a break
for three weeks
not too long
you know just a little something to
recharge your batteries
for sure it's been a long year
all [ __ ] righty then eh
so we'll see you guys tomorrow live
thursday 12 30 be there
and bring your cheese to put on those
crackers that's right that's right
that's right
there's already a c word it's the one
that's really derogatory against women
there might even be multiple
what's wrong with you it just goes to
show that you know maybe
when we have multiple of every letter of
the alphabet words that are bad
wait what's the other oh like a slur
again with the c in it yeah yeah
five percent
[Laughter]
all right we'll see you tomorrow guys
thanks for watching hope you had fun i
sure did congratulations to our
congratulations again callie percent
world champ 2021 we got to send her a
trophy or something definitely
or well i don't want to be too
aggressive we should make her a trophy
and have it here if she wants it she can
come get it or request that we send it
yeah
yeah
all righty guys
see you tomorrow
[Music]
foreign